okay to people just joining us we are
doing a first look
at jonathan's
category theory framework
and uh
uh
yeah take it away that's how where do we
start
okay right i'm assuming you can see you
can still see this blank i can see a
blank notebook so far we're we're just
it is what is it it's the non category
what is the the empty category oh yeah
usually usually we call the null
category
the object says the hamster to both null
sets okay
okay
so
to begin with it's probably easier
rather than going and introducing
categories straight off it's probably
easier if i introduce quivers which are
sort of the structural basis of all
categories in the framework so we have
this function abstract quiver where i
mean there's a bunch of different ways
you can call it but probably the easiest
is you just pass it an association of
arrows and objects those arrows connect
so
let's say labeled graph
so this would be equivalent right
um
hold on
go ahead so this way so sorry is the
right hand side of each of those rules
does it have to contain exactly two
things
uh yes so every every arrow it has to be
a binary relation um it doesn't actually
have to be it doesn't have to be a list
it can be anything
you know these could be directed edges
or whatever but i see
okay is there a reason i'm just
wondering if there's a reason that um
like if this could also be done using
tagged directed edges
so
with with these graphs that's exactly
how it's being done
and so it's important to know that
abstract quiver can accept graph objects
so if you pass it to directed graph it
will work i see so just as a matter of
syntax you could have given it a list of
tags directed edges instead of that
association there yes exactly and when
you pass it a graph that's exactly what
it's doing
sounds good constraints on the
quiver or is it just any collection of
arrows
uh any collection of arrows there are no
constraints and so um
you know quivers
effectively directed multi graphs so you
could have multi edges you can have self
loops um there's no constraint on what
you can do with with these
um and obviously so these are
i should just note obviously quivers are
like mathematically interesting
structures in their own right they come
out of representation theory they get
studied in the context of narrator
embedding and those kinds of things um
but
the
context in which they're relevant for us
is that they provide the underlying
structural basis for a category so the
reason why they're called quivers is
because they are collections of arrows
they are effectively categories where
you don't have uh composition and you
don't have identity
um
so
oh and wait wait wait wait let me just
unpass that past that thing
there are collections of arrows where
say that again
so it's just a collection about so a
category is a collection of arrows in
effect a quiver where you have this
binary operation which is composition
and where you have identity maps
okay so so
two errors in a row is not composition
uh no so in a no because if you take a
quiver like this right the fact that
there are two hours in a row doesn't
guarantee that there's an arrow from x
to z whereas if this were or x to z if
this were a category it would
so in fact okay let me just so
categories i mean these are just graphs
and categories are transitive graphs so
everything has a self view
right okay right so yeah right they're
transl so if i now show this
if i give it the underlying structure of
a quiver this is what you get exactly as
christopher said you effectively get the
transitive closure of this thing uh with
self-loops at every vertex
and so you've got g compose f that takes
you directly from x to z to z
this is all very beautiful the only
thing that isn't beautiful is the
graphic design of these graphs which i
think could and the fonts which could do
a little bit of work
um
but uh
but that's very nice okay
um
okay okay what are those
x tilde what's that right okay so those
are the those are the uh
symbols for the identity
so if we um
if i say
so those things can be overwritten so if
i say circle times and i say like over
bar or something
um that will replace the composition
operation with circle times rather than
circle dot which is the default and it
will replace uh over tilde with over bar
for the um for the uh again are those
the only optional things in abstract
code
so so if i wanted it i like
okay this is just a super detail don't
worry about but like that z bar
often one c a one
sub z being the identity on z
right right so i could do something like
subscript
one comma
i see
yeah
which might be a better default i i i
don't
oh who knows
right
um
but no okay so steven sorry to address
your question i should say i mean um
this will become more relevant later but
so categories have lots of different
options so that you can see a category
is defined by
this association so it's got um
effectively a collection it's got an
underlying quiver which is this thing
here
um and it's also got a collection of
equivalences between objects
equivalences between morphisms and it
has symbols for the composition of the
identity so to explain these
equivalences perhaps it's easiest if i
show that in the case of quivers first
so for something like this
if instead of saying full label graph i
said reduced label graph
then what i'm doing is i'm saying i want
the i want the labeled graph of this
quiver modded out by a certain set of
equivalences between the objects and the
arrows so i could have an equivalence
between objects i could say something
like x equals y
and that would reduce the thing to this
so now f is a is a self-loop effectively
and i could have uh equivalences between
the morphers between the arrows so i
could say g equals h and i get that for
instance
um and these um morphism equivalences
and object equivalences are the same
idea but now applied to cat to
categories rather than just oh hold on
first question is so the way those
equalities are being treated is
left hand side is going to right hand
side that's why the representative is y
not x
yes exactly and and i'm again i'm not
i'm not too dogmatic about which way
around that it felt natural to treat
them as like a left an lhs to rhs rule
but i can also see an argument that the
left-hand side should be the canonical
element in which case you should be it
should be okay all right fine but let's
just uh
my feeling is i don't really know but my
feeling is it might be more natural for
the left-hand side to be that but it
doesn't really matter but the basic
point is i agree the second argument of
an abstract quiver
by default is the equivalence between
objects and the third argument is the
equivalence between equivalences between
morphisms is that correct
that's correct i mean so again if you
want to be if you want to be really
pedantic the the actual structure is
it's uh you know the quiver internally
is an association of objects arrows
equivalences uh
equivalences between arrows and
equivalences between objects
i'm curiosity could you could you write
um the
g equals f instead of g equals h
uh yep
so that would now look like this and it
would be exactly the same oh like that
yeah okay wait a minute wait wait i
don't understand g
equals f
uh
shouldn't that mean that
shouldn't that mean that y equals x and
z equals y or something
if g equals f
yes but you so what you've done is
you've fed in
an incompatible set of
equivalences right
right
well i don't understand i don't
understand that hold on the the domains
and codomains of your equivalences don't
match up
right that's why i want to try that one
but i'm not i'm not sure i totally
understand what the result is
uh you know so this this should throw an
error um it doesn't right now
okay fine it should
this should throw something that says
you know domains and codomains don't
match
so so you can only given you can only
give an arrow equivalence if they're
basically just multi edges
well or if they're multi edges modulo
other equivalences right
okay sure yeah
could you canonicalize it and add
additional object equivalences to make
the
arrows yes yeah yeah you could and so
probably
actually that that's a fair point right
we could either have the thing just
throw
an error that says
these things don't match or try to find
the minimal set of object equivalences
that would make the you know make that
set of the the set of arrow equivalences
compatible
um what would be the analogous i mean
it's like a matrix multiply where the
where the you know whether sizes don't
match or something where we don't go and
try and search for
compatibility are there other examples
in algebra where we are for example
where we are searching for compatibility
roger do you have a thought or jose or
anybody
and think of one
i mean we though i take that back okay
we do um
we infer
like um
like a long time ago we introduced like
vector variables in nd solve and if you
give the initial value let's say that
that's a vector or a matrix then we
infer
that the the variable has to be a vector
or matrix of that dimension
right so probably there's an option go
ahead
yeah threaded construct
where you specify how two arrays thread
together
yes
what what about it i mean but yeah if we
don't do this
is it a scalar or a vector
right okay so this isn't a scalar vector
problem this is just a problem of of
you can give constraints you know where
it has to then figure out that that
they're you know based on the arrow
constraints it has to infer that there
are a bunch of object constraints but
there are different sets of object
constraints that it might infer and and
so on right so it's i don't see why that
may not be is the point that if you have
like x
you may want the x to represent a vector
but
um
you know the x could stand for a list
i'm not sure i think so i i think it's i
think it's more just that i think it's
more just that you you add one
constraint and then there are multiple
different i mean fundamentally what's
happening is i mean we're giving it you
know these the arrows and we're giving
it constraints and it's giving some
solution
some way of sort of identifying objects
and arrows so that uh you know that
obeys the equivalences and right now my
impression is that it's only doing that
when they're sort of
when there's sort of a trivial solution
right when when it's just like
multi-edges and and stuff like that but
but
you know if we allowed it to do more
complicated things then there might be
many different solutions and stuff like
that so i should mention this problem so
this this is treated in
some of this functionality just not
directly the level of equivalences so
like later on when we look at sort of
commutative diagrams and handling of
group voids and things there are
instances where we effectively have to
return the minimal set of equivalences
necessary to say make a diagram
commutative or turn a category into a
groupoid or something like that and so
in those cases we just return a
canonical set of equivalences that's
known to be the minimal one but
obviously in general there would be many
such
okay so let's move on there's actually
sorry one one last question is so is
there a reason why um in the association
represented the quiver why it
why does it have to store all the
equivalences and stuff why doesn't it
just bake it all in and then give it a
big set of arrows
oh so um
okay so
because we want to be able to
distinguish the full quiver from the
reduced quiver now for the particular
case of quivers that's it's not
immediately obvious why you'd want to do
that later on when for instance we want
to distinguish you know say epimorphisms
versus monomorphisms or something then
it becomes important which morphisms are
are lost and which morphisms are
preserved when one mods out by
equivalences so you need to know both
structures
i see okay this makes sense
okay should we move on
sure uh so okay so um again like doing
super basic stuff just to start with um
it's obviously worth noting that
obviously like the formal definition of
a category is something where you've got
objects morphisms you have composition
and crucially that composition satisfies
the axioms of associativity and the
axioms of uh identity reflectivity and
the you know th
that these um self-loops act as identity
morphisms so to show you an example of
how that works
so internally abstract category keeps
track of everything that's being
equivalent so here you can see h compose
g in brackets compose f but if i say
commutativity equations
uh
oh no sorry not uh associativity
equations
associativity
it returns the minimal set of equations
that that it internally is storing to
ensure associativity between these
morphisms um and similarly i could say
identity equations
and it's returning the minimal set of
equivalences needed to ensure i get that
these um self-loop arrows act as
identity morphisms so you know f is
equivalent to f compose x tilde et
cetera
so are you literally computing each all
the paths or
uh which to get out these equations
you set your minimal one so somehow you
know what what does minimal mean
okay minimal in this case just means
minimal and so
even minimal is not guaranteed to be
unique of course but it just means a
minimal
uh set of equivalences where we treat
where minimality is quantified in terms
of just cardinality of the set
i'm i'm confused here right so it's like
if you had if you had a four or four
levels of composition there might be a
couple different ways you could set up
the associativity equations right right
and if i if i say something like this we
get something that's a bit more
complicated but it will still return me
the the minimal set of associativity
equations
the one that doesn't show all the
additional edges
sorry
the property labeled graph does that uh
oh so there should be a property
labelled graph uh there isn't right now
but you know the the one that doesn't
show all the additional edges would just
be you you get out the underlying quiver
and you say you know full label
can you even say like transitive
reduction of the full labeled graph does
that do anything useful
uh so it you know in the case like this
it obviously would and it would give you
uh if you did transfer production of
yeah it would
brilliant okay
okay so let me understand this so
you're labeling that thing at the top
with these unassociated
h
dot g dot f type things
and then you're saying go ahead when you
say unassociated
well i mean i mean that you've still got
parentheses in it
yes but but but the parentheses are the
sort of canonical parentheses
right okay
this this arrow here h compose g compose
f
this equation is telling us that that's
the same as h compose g composite we're
just returning the right hand side one
because that's the canonical element
but
why do you i mean
isn't it the axioms of category theories
say that that could just be written h
dot g dot f without parentheses
sure is that true yeah sure i think i
think the composition here is is it is a
binary operator i mean our maybe the
rendering shouldn't show the parentheses
unless necessary
well okay so oh no that is
that is what's happening it's this is
like a precedence issue of
circle
dot right
right right and and maintaining it as a
binary operator is incredibly useful
later on when we do kind of fear
improving stuff over these things okay
all right okay so this is just a way of
saying we've canonicalized a bunch of
you know there are many many different
ways that we could have parenthesized
these things and the things on the right
are the canonical ones that we show
right it's sort of unfortunate that we
can't
it probably breaks lots of things if we
use the actual function composition
instead of circle dot or something like
that but i did consider it inactivate or
inactive of composition but it just
seemed too weird
i'm sure we can have something which is
a special
character there that can have
appropriate you know behavior anyway
let's keep going
we could imagine an inactive composition
that is actually introduced as a
syntactic form i mean when would you
want it to activate
but you know if that was
okay
well i mean if if there's an actual
representation of this category right if
you give an interpretation that that
says you know these objects are actually
you know these data structures and these
morphisms are these functions then you
might want it to evaluate
the process of replacing you know the f
g's and h's with the actual functions is
sort of involved enough that you might
as well also replace the composition
part you know what i mean
yeah probably i mean there's a symbolic
fg and h for now okay keep going all
right so
boy this this gets to be a surprisingly
complicated diagram surprisingly quickly
despite the fact that note that that
graph is totally trivial if you look at
the transit of reduction you know this
is just a path graph but with all the
the the this is the transitive closure
of a path graph
yes right yeah right
right exactly uh well actually in that
spirit maybe i can show the commutative
diagram
stuff so obviously one of the most
fundamental things you can do in
category theory and homological algebra
is say you know such and such a diagram
commutes
uh so let me give you a bit like the
simplest or a simple example of that and
then show how you can make it a bit more
complicated
so here we have um
so actually both the full label graph
and the reduced label
the underlying quiver structure has
something like this so here we have a
just a square right
so you can see there are two different
paths that take me from x to w
so what it means if i say i want this
diagram to commute is i what is it um is
that i want the function obtained by
composing
by applying f then h to be the same as
the function obtained by applying g then
i and we can see that that's not true a
priori by the from the fact that there
are two edges that go from x to w in the
full labeled graph
uh and hence commutative diagram shows
us false so if i say
communicative diagram q
it will say false but what i can do i
can see that just by looking at it that
if i wanted to make this diagram commute
i just have to impose an additional
equivalence that h compose f is equal to
i compose g
um
to get to that quiver full labeled graph
that is the transitive reduction of
the
the graphs above is that correct i mean
if i took
to create the category was just the
quiver and it only expanded out into
this this form
right right right this is now showing
explicitly that you've got different
functions different morphisms h composer
f i compose g
oh sorry go on
does
commutativity of a diagram just mean
that you have arrow equivalences for
every
uh pair of arrows from the same
objects
uh
not necessarily pair it's it's in
general just saying that every path
for any two objects
in the in the top graph then right right
every pair of paths between those two
objects must be
so if you had a third edge you'd want
all three of them to be equivalent
right exactly okay and
so for
um
for object equivalences in a category
are those isomorphisms or
uh
so
okay um
isomorphisms are kind of their own thing
isomorphisms are morphisms that are left
and right invertible
um
so
so
you're saying that your notion of
equivalence doesn't require
that
no equivalence is much stronger than
that equivalence is saying these things
really are identical i see isomorphism
is a is a weaker constraint
which will again i'll show i mean
there's there's a lot of built-in
functionality for handling things like
isomorphisms okay keep going keep going
right so if i say commutativity
equations it will return again the
minimal set of equations necessary to
force this diagram to commute so if i
add that in now we get commutative
diagram showing true
and reduce labeled graph now has it
collapses this
you know this pair of multi edges to
just a single edge
and if you do transfer reduction of that
it won't change
right the underlying quiver structure is
the same
but the wait a minute you just added g
compose i is the same as f compose h is
that right that was your command so it
man it managed to remove h compose f as
sort of a redundant edge
and and now but that but both of those
are both like they're transitive edges
they're removed in the reduction
right so so the the the the quiver
doesn't care right nothing nothing we're
doing here modifies the underlying
quiver structure
okay
um so this seems a bit trivial but
obviously like
um commutative diagrams
get pretty complicated pretty quickly so
if i give a slightly more
complex example i was going to ask i
mean how often is that i mean in this
case it's pretty clear oh they're these
two you know there's just this set these
two edges you've got to make equivalent
but in a more complicated thing are
there actually like lots of choices that
you could that you could go with yes
yeah no exactly so the actual set of
equations that's implied by a
commutative diagram is in general not
obvious there'll be many uh potential
choices and again you could do a whole
you could do a grid quiver that would be
interesting
right right exactly i mean so this is
the beginning of a grid oh hang on wait
this is meant to be the beginning of a
grid quiver but i've done it done
something incorrectly
f2 is repeated
oh thank you uh
i mean to say
what do i want to say i want to say g1
is that yeah thanks jose right this is
the beginning of a grid quiver so this
is two whereas this is just a commu what
one might call a commutative square this
is what in homological algebra would be
called a a commutative oblong so it's
just two commutative squares glued on
top of each other all right just to
humor me sorry could could you type
abstract category of grid graph of
something or other
uh yeah do you have a favorite graph
i don't know grid graph five five
uh is it oh celebrate basis
okay so this is um i i'm i'm not
convinced that's going to turn i'm not
that's probably already too many paths
you might also want to say directed
edges yeah directed edges to true
right okay uh if i say abstract category
of that i'm not convinced this is going
to run oh gosh okay we've got 53
morphisms there
i mean for for graphs 53 is nothing
right i mean that's nice but like for
categories
that's pretty hard to understand this is
f53 including all the transitive closure
edges yes yeah of course yeah okay so if
you do transfer reduction on that you
should get a grid
right or if we say yeah with a graph um
where the f's coming from
well because you didn't we didn't call
the edges anything so by default
abstract quiver and by extension
abstract category calls the morphisms f1
f2 f3 etc
that should probably be something a
little bit more elaborate i mean it
probably should be some more not just a
you know
a letter f it should be some
chosen non typeable formal thing of
something or shouldn't be the dotted f
for something is now we do in other
places
because otherwise you're not
distinguishing in this case the objects
are given numbers
but the edges
oh i mean did you do canonical graph on
a graph does it convert everything to
integers
yes
and actually
if it's an if it's an f should it be
should it be indexed of f or subscript
of f is indexed only for things that are
really vectors
i'm not sure
yes
it's uh
you know if you substitute an array
there it will use part
but i mean if we have if we have 10 f's
you know that aren't it's not there's no
vector involved f is not a vector but
we just need 10 names is it would it be
a mistake to use indexed
i think yes because i think we're going
to have more support for
things that are you know uh hidden
crypto
vector variables and things like that
um
i'm not sure christopher i i uh
okay let's let's move on because i think
jonathan probably has a lot to show i
just wanted to see something a
programmatically generated category
diagram because i don't think those are
very common and i should i should say
like you know something like this
uh it's very very non-obvious what the
minimal set of equations you'd need to
make this diagram commute would be but
i believe
if i say connectivity equations
it will return what equations need to be
satisfied
and what is that algebraically can you
just describe what was done to find
those equations
uh
well actually so so what's really being
done is graph theoretic right so so to
get a set of equations you just need to
pair off
uh you know pairs of multi edges
i see
um and then we do uh essentially
algebraic reduction on the you know on
that set of equations to remove
redundancies and we just return the
first
cool okay
all right so yeah so i was going to i
mean that lets me show that example now
but if
i what i was going to show was like in
case of a commutative oblong
what am i doing commutativity equations
for the case of a commutative oblong
uh
that's now
that's now saying commutative
diagram true
that's the reduced labeled graph with
the with these multi edges modded out
effectively
um so anyway so this immediate i mean
this immediately automates a lot of kind
of um proof methods in homological
algebra and category theory because
there's a
an awful lot of arguments in both fields
essentially reduced to diagram chasing
you know reduced to something where you
you generate some big complicated
looking diagram and then you say this
commutes and and so abstract category
will tell you the minimal set of
assumptions you need for that statement
to be true
nice um
okay uh and i should oh i should mention
like you know once you introduce those
equations you can say what are the
reduced commutativity equations and
things like that so you can say what are
the commutative equations if i mod out
by the equivalences and of course in
this case because we because we've now
got a commutative diagram this thing has
reduced to the empty list even though
commutative equations are still that
um
okay uh so maybe i should show some
computations you can do to kind of get
interesting properties of categories out
so if i say
let's take the example of monomorphisms
and epimorphisms because they're a nice
sort of simple starting place
so um
so um
i'll load those both up because we'll
need them both so a monomorphism is
essentially a generalization of the idea
of an injective function so it's a
morphism that is left cancellative or
injective
so in that case what it means is that
so we've got here two
we've got a morphism f and we have two
other morphisms that go into f g1 and g2
from some common object z
and
so if i now say
um
don't you need to say that it's not by
name right you need to say it
i need to say to say what sorry
which ones are mono and which ones are
well so it will it will compute this
right so um
you can see but
you know initially everything's a mono
uh but if i now say um
circle dot uh what do i want to say i
want to say circle f comma g one equals
circle dot f g two
so now the reduced label graph looks
like this so you can see we've got f
composed g1 is equal to f composed g2
and if this if f is a monomorphism that
should imply that g1 equals g2 but it
doesn't so far we've still got g to g1
and g2 being separate so you can see
that f has now gone to false f is no
longer a monomorphism but if we
introduce the additional relation that
g1 equals g2
then our reduced label graph collapses
to this and now f becomes a mono again
and so as i say this is effectively the
generalization of
what it means to be an injective
function because you're saying if i take
f and i apply it i want it to be the
case that if f applied to g one is equal
to f applied to g two then g one equals
g two
that's the definition of a monomorphism
uh and i could do and i could do the
same thing with epimorphism so i could
say
uh category 4 is that and then
so i want to say
y zed
y said
and we can say
sorry category 4.
by the way when it says monomorphisms
you know oh and when it said something
like um f goes to false in the
monomorphisms list or association it's
not
f isn't necessarily not a monomorphism
it's just that assuming that g you know
you don't know whether g1 and g2 are
equivalent and so you you don't know
whether it's a monomorphism no this is
the question of generations are not
equivalent
by default
right right exactly so so you you see
that with with commutative diagram and
all this other stuff uh if we if there
is no explicit equivalence between
implied between the two uh between the
two morphisms they are assumed to be
inequivalent i see it okay
um which is like what we do with generic
solutions to equations
it's solved versus reduce there could
alternatively be a reduce that would
give the implied conditions necessary
for f to be a monomorphism
right right uh and so in fact we do that
again in the in the groupoid subsystem
we we have functions for doing that that
will tell you what what's the minimal
set of equations you need to make things
isomorphisms or monomorphisms or
whatever
um
so actually okay let me show you
uh right so then epimorphisms would be
if i wanted to say circle dots the
function properties function injective
function surjective and so on does that
too for normal functions
does what sorry does the gives you the
conditions for it to be true
right which is by the way very analogous
to this
monomorphism
thing so that's a something
it's not analogous it's a special case
um yes i realized that but i'm saying
that the design thing where what we have
injective function
of f
is our way of determining whether that
function you know this is a more
symbolic version of that notion of the
function f
in the case of injective function of f
it's the injective function of you know
sine of cosine of tangent of x or
something it takes the body
of a
function instead of a
in terms of a pure symbolic name yeah
exactly but by the way maybe as a
as a design question maybe instead of
calling epimorphisms it could be called
like epimorphism q which means that you
could both have like a second argument
where you give it uh so first of all if
you say epimorphisms it sounds like it
should return a list of things which are
hypomorphisms as opposed to like whether
they are and the other thing is that it
might be nice to have like a two
argument version of that where you give
it an a you know an an arrow and it
tells you whether it's an epimorphism
right no i agree so actually this is one
of the um
well certainly related to one of the
questions that i wanted to ask on the
agenda which was so right now these are
just properties of abstract category um
but i can also see an argument like
steven i think we discussed this sort of
back in december or something that all
of these things like mono monomorphisms
epimorphisms etc should be separate
functions in which case they could have
properties that would do exactly what
you're saying christopher that would
where you could say
you could feed it a second argument that
takes in a particular morphism or you
you it could feed back an operator form
that tells you whether a given arrow is
an epimorphism or whatever
um and i i i don't know what the best
design for the corresponding terms for
injective insurgent would be epimorphic
and
right right so you you want monomorphic
q an epimorphic q well just monomorphic
and then it gives conditions
yeah right
right okay but but the thing that i
think is going to determine a bunch of
these design issues is what the
interface between the abstract category
way of setting things up and kind of
landing so to speak
in you know
something where there are explicit
forms for f and the objects and so on
is that do we expect that there is such
an interface or do we think it's going
to all live in the clouds
well so
there definitely is right so um the
reason i'm calling all these things
abstract categories is because so in
category theories there's a distinction
made between an abstract category which
is just something that satisfies the
axioms of category theory and a concrete
category which is a category that's
equipped with a faithful functor onto
the category set so where in effect you
are giving an interpretation of
um of each object as a set and you're
giving an interpretation of each arrow
as a set valued function so for us that
would mean we'd want a notion of
concrete category that for instance
takes every object to a list and every
arrow as a function from list to list
okay
okay and what will be some early i mean
in terms of the rest of the system how
would that interface what would what
would like a commutative diagram chasing
you know
story b in terms of the rest of the
system is that
some
is that effectively giving us a bunch of
equivalences between
functions somehow
in other words how would that
well right exactly it would give you
equations on functions and on function
application
which is something we don't right now
have and we don't have the capability to
take lambdas effectively
and
do operations on those
and is this perhaps
i mean we do in the theorem prover right
in what sense
in the sense that the the operators you
can think of as being abstract functions
and we're reasoning over equivalences
between those operators
yes that's true
that's true right keep going keep going
let's this is right now okay whatever so
i was just going to show you know
epimorphisms biomorphisms which are just
you know uh things that are both
monomorphisms and epimorphisms things
like that um we also have support for um
what else could i reason i mean what
else is useful for me to sh oh i i okay
like
just because i it because i think it's
instructive to other stuff clearly
notions like monomorphisms and
epimorphisms are dual to each other in
the sense that if i just took this
picture and i inverted all the arrows
and i reversed the direction of
composition i would get the other the
corresponding epimorphism picture and
again can i just say reverse graph
you couldn't just say reverse graph
because that wouldn't modify function
composition in the right way
right right
it would structurally give you the right
thing but what you actually want to do
is say dual category
and it will give you
the dual
structurally is the reverse graph of
that but you can see the edges have been
relabeled so that the um
why those edges are not
bezier curves they don't have the
slightest idea why did they have little
glitchifies glitchy fires in them that's
so weird see that i mean there's a bunch
of straight edges there and the g1
compose f
edge
it's very hard okay
not for the not this group not this
meeting okay
keep going
but anyway we'll see that a lot where
you've got two concepts that are that
are due that are you know in duality and
that those can that can easily be seen
just by using dual category
um okay so there's a corresponding there
are corresponding notions like uh
retractions and sections so if i take um
go back to saying sorry before you get
to that
what's the difference between a
biomorphism and an isomorphism
oh okay so uh
right so monomorphism remember
monomorphisms and epimorphisms are just
uh cancellative so so a monomorphism is
left cancellative and an epimorphism is
right cancellative there's also notions
that there's also the notion of
retractions versus sections which means
left invertible and right invertible so
an isomorphism is one that's left
invertible and right inversable whereas
a bimorphism is one that's left
cancellative and right cancellative i
see
uh so
uh
so the like being a left inverse implies
that you are right cancellative and
being a right inverse implies that you
are left cancellative so they are
related but they're not the same concept
this is what you're about to show that's
what i was about to show yeah
right so uh a retraction is the left
inverse of a morphism and a a section is
a right inverse so if i say say this
it's probably the simplest example i can
show
i say
retractions
isomorphism is one that's is animorphism
that's both a retraction and a section
in other words it's both a left inverse
and a right it has both a left inverse
and a right inverse
so um
you can see now that if i say so you can
so okay right because i've got an f and
a g and they they effectively one goes
from x to y and one goes from y to x you
can see there are two ways for me to get
from x to itself i can take the identity
arrow or i could do g compose f
similarly i could take the identity
arrow on y or i could do f compose g and
again a priori we don't know that these
uh these two arrows are the same but i
could impose a condition that says g
compose f is
over tilde x
so i get that
and now you can see that g has become a
retraction and f has become a section
because a retraction is a left inverse
section as a right inverse
and although neither of them is is an
isomorphism and similarly i could say
circle dot
circle dot f compose g
over tilde y
and i get that and now you can see that
f has now become a retraction and g has
become a section and both of them are
now isomorphisms
um and so
sorry was that
um okay so
what i can then show is
we can look at a particular kind of
category which is a groupoid
which is a category in which every
morphism is an isomorphism so if i
remove these again i get back to that if
i say groupoid q
it will say no but i can say
groupoid equations and it will return
the minimal set of equations i need to
force this category to be a group point
which in that case is exactly the set of
equations we imposed above g compose f
is x tilde and f composed g is y tilde
so if i include those again
that reduces and now group point two
returns true but i get uh but just as
with the commutative diagram case it
very quickly just becomes rather
complicated so if i say
uh say f one goes from x to y g one goes
from y to z f two goes uh sorry f2 goes
from y to x g2 goes from z to y
uh
and this
becomes
already really very messy
there are a whole bunch of different
ways that i can get from
certain objects to certain other objects
and from certain objects to themselves
but i can again say and again it's like
pretty obvious this is not a groupoid
because there are many many different
self-loops for each object
alright but i can say throughpoint
equations
impose these
now reduce labeled graph collapses to
this which is much more civilized and
groupoid queue returns true eventually
there we go
um and so
we just understand this object
so just just remind me what's a group
word again it's not a semi group
no no so a groupoid is exactly is
defined as exactly this right it's
defined as a category in which every
morphism is an isomorphism
but it's also a function purely purely
algebraic right what's the algebraic
definition of an in universal algebra
what is a group void
there is no universal algebraic
definition of a group that's that's
inequivalent to the category theory
definition
you could you could write a
um the joke is that a group is a
groupoid with one object
it's well yeah in effect that's the
definition right because if if you
imagine a if you imagine a groupoid with
one object
then
every every morphism is an isomorphism
so every morphism is invertible you have
identity maps by the axioms of a
category and you have associativity by
the axioms of a category so you've got a
group where the group elements are
exactly the morphisms of that single you
know category with a single object
so if if you wanted to define it
universal algebraically you could just
say
i replace the binary operation of a
group with a partial function and then i
get a group point but that's just a more
elaborate way of stating the category
theory definition
and say the category theory definition
again
the category in which every morphism is
an isomorphism or every morphism is
invertible
and graph theoretically isn't it also
just that every connected component is
the complete graph
uh
depends on exactly how you define
complete graph in this case
well i mean i guess it's it's transitive
and so
you know and then and everything is an
isomorphism so you have it sort of a
undirected um or you have sort of the
bi-directional arrows and
for everything right
right
but crucially you can't have more than
one pair of bi-directional arrows right
it has to be commutative
sure right which makes it so so you
can't even have like a
i guess you couldn't even have like a
multi-complete graph if you know what i
mean
right right exactly
but so wait a minute so the case so a
group void of size four with four
objects in it
can you can you show that
uh i mean again you could see even with
three objects this is this got quite a
bit i mean
um
so first of all which group point of
size four do you want uh how many are
there
well
there's one for every um undirected
graph with four vertices right
okay so how do you go from a
okay
this
this would be a triangle graph is that
true that this came from or a triangle
with self loops
the triangle group graph would uniquely
uh so in effect you want the graph to be
undirected right because you need it
needs to be the case that you that for
every if you can go from x to y you can
go from y to x sure
um so any any so this would just be the
undirected graph you know an undirected
triangle graph
that would define this groupoid
okay i understand but if you have a
bigger graph
what
um
given a graph
how do you get the corresponding group
void given an undirected graph
is the corresponding group boy just
the thing with every undirected edge
turned into a pair of edges and you know
selfies for self loops
except plus all the groupoid equations
what does that mean you mean
can you show an example just just the
four okay
this is an example right that's kind of
the point of what i was trying to show
so um
i mean if you want to like there's no
particular reason to do it this way
around but oh do it for four do it for
four
i need a graph right okay well so okay
you're showing me from this graph
yeah i'm just for some reason you seem
to want to do it with a
i'm going to just repeat exactly what i
did up here but with a graph
so
if i say that
what is this actually doing here why is
it taking so long what is it actually
doing
well it's computing the category from
that underlying quiver which is
obviously going to be quite
complicated
uh isn't it just going to be basically
that
maybe i should start with that because
that's
more analogy you're not computing the
groupoid directly you're first computing
the
category nothing to say that it is a
group right so i mean this is the
category
yeah you're not going straight from this
quiver to a minimal groupoid
no i mean
we could we could have a function
abstract groupoid which did that
but
um again that's like something i wanted
to discuss here
curiosity that that computation time
that was that was just for display right
if you put a semicolon after it would
have been instant oh yeah
of course yeah okay yeah
that's that's entirely display
um
so that that's the graph we started from
this is the category from that you can
see these are going to get complicated
really quickly because now you've got a
bunch of cycles and each one of those
you know every path through those cycles
corresponds to a different new arrow
you're going to introduce
and you recursively repeat that process
right this is why these things get get
so complicated
so i'm sorry just just sort of zooming
out for a second here you know one of
the things i've long been curious about
is how do you put functions onto a graph
that is how do you think of a graph you
know you could think of f
composed with g composed h or something
that's just a chain
and
is this
in some sense this is a way of
decorating a graph
with functions on the edges
is that a way that i should think about
categories in general
that it's a way of taking a graph
and
with the axioms of function composition
as usually defined
i mean that's a way you can think about
what a
category is
right
okay so because that's interesting as a
general thing in language because it's
basically saying you know just as we can
define we have tree-like expressions
usually but these are in a sense graph
like expressions is that a first
statement or is that you know normally
we have functions that are sort of
composed with each other
in tree-like forms
but this is but there are many there are
many
graphs can be
models for many different phenomena so
even for function composition
like a neural net
um
those are basically those are function
compositions but we we describe how they
compose
what is the relationship between a
neural net and a category way of saying
how things compose
because you have a bunch of outputs that
are going to connect to a bunch of
inputs like how what's the topology
there how are things wired up yes but
you know and you think of a circuit you
know combinational circuits
those are the blocks or functions
the wires are compositions
as opposed to in this case where the
where the wires are functions
right
there are many many ways that graphs are
modeled structural models for things in
life
including for functions
okay
i'm more to ask about that but keep
going keep going uh okay well i mean
there's there's a bunch of functionality
okay abstract category has loads of
functionality for doing similar things
and i let me not in the interest of
saving time let me not go through all of
them but like you know for instance you
can compute endomorphisms automorphisms
you know initial objects terminal object
terminal objects constant morphisms
coconorphisms zero objects all those
kinds of things so when you say you can
compute you have a given category go
ahead
does that does that largely reduce to
graph algorithms yes yes so so most of
what we're doing here is algebra is
doing essentially abstract algebraic
computations via graph theory which
means it should scale pretty good
but so for example
categories only or do you envision this
for
right right okay that's a really good
question so um so right now it only
works for for finite you know for things
you can specify with associations so for
finite categories of course most
categories the category theorists would
care about are not just infinite they're
actually non-small
um so in so again like in in ct it's
common to make a distinction between
small categories and non-small
categories so a small category is one
where the object set and the hom set the
set of morphisms are both sets
but most in most categories they won't
be sets they'll be proper classes so for
instance in set
they clearly aren't sets because the um
object set is the class of is is all
possible sets which you know can't be a
set it has to be a proper class um and
similarly you know for similar reasons
top the category of topological spaces
or rung the category of rings etc these
are all non-small categories so what
would be lovely is if we had a purely
symbolic way of representing infinite
and indeed non-small
categories
that's what we did in the pure math
entity store packlets which basically
just symbolic representations but
couldn't do any computations with them
right and how
and ian the
if you
fed in this category theory capabilities
into those
symbolic representations could you
actually get more mileage there
it's kind of why i was asking jonathan i
don't i don't even see how they fit
together
um because this is so
you know you have it this is like
discreet you have finite numbers of
objects and edges
you're not trying to reason about
um
you know infinite things
well the question is there's some
qualified version of this
when you say infinite i mean the sets
can be infinite right there's no
well so it would be like you would have
an infinite number of of vertices in the
graph
right okay potentially
but not even
vertices it might be a class of vertices
like jonathan was saying sure sure i i
got it yeah
okay but but so when you say you can
test for automorphism that
what you're saying is you can give the
conditions on one of these categories
on one of these categories
for the thing to be an automorphism is
that right
for a for a given morphism to be an
automorphism yeah so
um
i don't know let's let's do a boring
category
um
and just as i was showing before you
know um
with monomorphisms epimorphism
isomorphism etc we can do automorphisms
we can do you know endomorphisms
etc so an end so in this context you
know endomorphism is any morphism that
maps an object to itself
uh and automorphism is any endomorphism
that is also an isomorphism uh etc so
there's a whole sort of zoology of these
things
okay okay
uh right anyway all i wanted to say was
the abstract category is i've tried to
design it so that it does kind of all
the standard bureaucracy you'd expect
from a cat you know
every every special kind of morphism
every special kind of object etc should
be you know there should be a way of
computing it
um okay but that's probably i
i probably said enough about abstract
categories for
can you compute the inverse smartphone
like for your group weight can you ask
for
inverse of any morpheus
uh yes i mean in effect that's what the
okay so the the the full version of
retractions and sections would do that
right that the that if if we were to
break that house into a separate if we
were to break those into separate
functions it would tell you what
a given morph is you know it would tell
you not just this morphism is a
retraction but what morphism it is a
retraction of and same with sections
where there's no way like the reduced
graph doesn't contain the inverse right
it's there's no inversion that reduced
graph there
for the group point
wait what what do you mean
like
you say that groupoid is
the category that contains all of the
inverses right for every morpheme right
so
so does it mean that
the f1 should contain it should have an
inverse right which is f2
then
okay
how does it compute that that it's f2 is
inverse
what do you mean how can you actually
compute it okay is there a way to
compute this like ask
for it like give me inverse of f1 so
that it would give me f
that's what i'm saying so in the full
version of this you would want to say
what is a retraction of what and what is
a section of what and therefore right so
you might want to have a function a
property there called inverses or
something which would give you for every
object for every morphism it would give
you the inverse morphism just as pairs
but but it's not
right but
the point i'm trying to make is that
that's it's not going to be as simple as
that right because a single morphism
could have multiple retractions a single
morphem could have multiple sections
um so it's it's actually it's going to
be a list of
stuff in general i see so there isn't
there isn't a unique inverse of morphism
i mean
i don't see why i mean obviously there
are categories in which there would be
but in general that wouldn't okay there
in general there isn't okay i didn't
know that i mean yeah
well in general there's no there's no
inverse um
there might be no inverse but can there
be two inverses
yeah as i say a a given morpheme could
have multiple retractions for instance
that happens a lot in topology
um
the diagram the diagram can
explicitly show that f2 is a f1 inverse
if it knows that
right i think that diagram is showing
that i mean
because you can see there's only one
arrow from x to x and it's x tilde
but if i if there was if if f2 and f3
were both inverses of f1 what you would
see there is an f1 arrow going one way
from x to y and the f2 and f3 arrows
both going from y to x is that correct i
mean yeah this is why i showed the
earlier example right that's why i tried
to
take pains to illustrate the simpler
case something like this right
so in this case you can see that f is
not f and g are not mutual inverses
because there are multi edges here
g compose f is not the same as x tilde
and f compose g is not the same as y
tilde
okay
so we still have to trace it in order to
see it and i'm just suggesting maybe you
should actually
as a label show that
g there g1 is f inverse
right which as i say would be exactly
what a full function form of sections
and retractions would do
but on the diagram on the diagram just
not not asking for any properties just
by looking at the diagram i should
already understand what is the inverse
of morpheme
not tracing it
over any loops there so nick what are
you actually suggesting is drawn on this
diagram
not on this one when the group the group
point just the labels
when you have f1
obviously i agree if we had a function
this is related to what we were
discussing earlier right if we had a
function which represented abstract
groupoids then i absolutely agree would
make sense to show the inverses i don't
think it makes sense to show the
inverses on an abstract category because
then why wouldn't we you know why
wouldn't we also retractions or all the
sections or the you know whatever right
so it just seems like abstract groupoid
is something that there's another option
for groupoids would be to just use a
single edge it's labeled with
both
i don't know if that would mess with
anything
yeah i mean you again again like for
group points in particular you could
imagine having special rendering where
every where instead of these being
directed edges they're undirected and
they're as you say they're labeled with
mutual inverses or something you could
yeah that would make sense for abstract
groupoid it wouldn't make sense for
abstract category i'd argue
right sounds right to me
okay onward right sorry anyway what i
want to do what i want to get on to is
actual comp not just bureaucracy but
actual computation so maybe i should
show something like abstract functor
um so if i take again let's just
generate a boring category
xyz
i say abstract functor
category let's call that
let's call that functor
obviously a definition of a functor is
just any it's a function between
categories that preserves uh function
composition and it preserves composition
and preserves identity so you know
functor applied to
f compose g should be function of f
composed function of g etcetera and you
know all the axioms should be maintained
so it's effectively a homomorphism
between categories
so
if i show the the input form of functor
you can see what it's doing is it's
taking in an underlying category um let
me
break this out here it's taking an
underlying category
it's saying here here's an association
of object mappings telling you what maps
to what here's an association of arrow
mappings telling you what maps to what
um here a new has a list of new objects
and a list of new arrows that are
produced and here are additional um
equivalences between objects and
morphisms that are produced in the image
uh we also want to be able to specify
whether the um
whether this function is covariant in
other words whether it preserves or
reverses the direction of arrows and
compositions and also what the
new symbols for composition and identity
would be in this new category that's
that's the sort of full form of a
functor
um
so you see in the default case when you
just feed it a category it will assume
an endo functor so if i say endofunctor
q will return true that just means it
category a function from a category to
itself so if i say a full labeled graph
we can see so you could give abstract
functure of category one comma category
two and then it would be a mapping or
category one arrow category two no
you you couldn't do that because there
would not be enough information in in
just that mapping to tell you which
morph is mapped to which other morphisms
you have to actually build it up
algebraically like this
um so what i was going to show what what
does abstract functor of a category like
what is that doing it's killing the
center functor right so it's just it's
treating the trivial case where you've
just got like a an identity functor from
the
or again what is called an endo functor
that just maps a category to itself okay
um
so if i were to then say so i could do
something a bit more
interesting i could say you know so here
i'm going to have an association of
object mappings so i can say x goes to a
uh you know y goes to b
uh
c or something and then i could also say
i don't know
i could have a mapping between arrows i
could say you know f goes to func so
that's no longer an endofunctor these
two categories are no longer equivalent
actually maybe it's easiest if i show
domain
and image
so you can see this is the category
that's now being mapped to with the
objects and the functions relabel and
obviously func is now used in the not
just in the original arrow but in all
the compositions that involve that arrow
and so on
uh but i could also say something like
uh i can also introduce some new objects
i can introduce u and v
so if i say so now domain is the same
but image now looks like this i could
introduce some new arrows i could say
um you know f2 goes from u to v
and i get now my image looks like that
or i could say wait wait wait wait wait
wait that that
fourth argument uv what the heck is that
so th this is the these are the new
objects that are introduced by this
functor so a function can introduce
objects and they can also remove them so
and it can introduce arrows and it can
remove arrows so the way so you have to
specify which new which new object and
which new arrow is being introduced
which is what these two arguments show
and then you can also add equivalences
that effectively take objects and morph
morphisms away just like they do in
ordinary categories oh yeah so what's
argument number two
this is the morph these are the mappings
between objects okay and the argument
number three isn't happening between
morphisms
and arguments
could be because again like you want to
you the um
you're actually mapping between arrows
in the underlying quiver because these
these names should be preserved when you
do compositions
um sorry just
is it because it's sort of convenient to
the automation of having sort of um
category to category and then you just
add to it basically
right right in effect yeah you one
doesn't want to have the situation where
you're giving directly mappings between
morphisms because then you could end up
you could have a situation where a
person is specifying a functor that is
actually ill-formed where it doesn't
where the image doesn't satisfy the
axioms of category theory right so if
you specify the um mappings between the
arrows then you then abstract function
functor can take care of that for you
right
makes sense
and uh again can i ask um object you
said objects and arrows can be removed
it they can only be removed through
equivalence right
right right exactly whereas new new
things can just be added wholesale and
then you add additional
right right and again that's part of the
sort of axiomatic definition of a
functor that you that
um everything every object has to map
every object in the in the domain has to
map to an object in the codomain every
functor in the um sorry every um
morphism in the domain has to matter
morphism in the codomain
but there could then be non-trivial
equivalences between those objects and
those morphisms yeah
yeah i guess i could rephrase like you
don't have like partial functors
uh that i think there is a notion of
partial functors but that's not abstract
function isn't intended to support that
um and i think that i think they only
get used in rather
abstruse parts of theoretical computer
science
um
how many arguments does abstract functor
have
well there are lots of different ways of
specifying it right so i mean again the
the true form is this association here
this this multi-argument version is just
a sort of uh a convenient way of
specifying it
okay
but that was also going to show you know
if i i could impose something like
uh b equals c
and then that would reduce to that and
so i could say that that's a way that i
could get rid of objects i could get rid
of arrows in the same in the same way
um
and if i want to do if i took so where
so this is a covariant functor uh i
could take
this thing
and i could say
functor two equals that and i could just
swap um
where is it
uh covariance is true i could change
that to false and now i get a
contravariant functor and if i show a
full label after that
now you can see this is the same as
graph a functor but now you know arrows
have been reversed function composition
has been reversed
um
and so
function cube will now say false to go
very covariant factor q and choose a
contrary function q
but there are other things that you
could check so uh for instance you could
so
one has a notion of full functors and
faithful functors for instance so a full
functor is one that's injective on
homsets and a faithful function is one
that's subjective on homsets so if i
take uh something like this and
uh let me let me figure out a minimal
case of
something like that so if i
get rid of these for the time being
um
image of that
uh okay so if this introduced a new
arrow between say b and c so if i
introduced g2 from b to c
sorry actually before i do that let me
just show if i call
oh [ __ ] you
untrue if i call faithful front of the
queue
and because both of these are true we'll
also return true for fully faithful
functor um
if i now have this thing introduce a new
arrow so if i say g2 goes from uh y to
uh or from b to c i should say sorry
like that so now we have something that
looks like this
then uh full functor q will now return
false faithful function q will now
return true but faithful function q will
now will still return true because in
effect what we've done is the
the um if we treat this function as a
collection of functions between hom sets
i.e a collection of functions between
the
sets of morphisms between pairs of
objects that this function is now no
longer injective
uh for this particular case because
we're generating a new arrow between a
and c
so because of that it's no longer a full
functor although it is still a faithful
functor because it's still surjective um
similarly if i were to take this
uh if i were to have this be um
i don't know let's say something like
uh
actually let me make the category now
have multi edges in it
maybe that's an easy way to show what i
mean
and so now if this took away if i had um
something which now stripped out
one of these morphisms like this
uh then full function q would return
true but faithful functor q now returns
false because now in effect by imposing
this equivalence we've made this
function no longer subjective on the
home sets
um anyway so all i'm trying to say is
that there are you know just like for
for categories there are lots of
properties of functors that we could try
to compute in this way we could ask for
you know what's the complete list of
what's the complete association of
mappings between the morphisms uh lots
of these kinds of things
um
okay does that mean
okay the reason i want to introduce
functors though is because so many of
the actual sort of interesting
categorical constructions depend on well
they depend on diagrams which are in
turn formalized in terms of functions so
in category theory the way one thinks
about a diagram is that it's just a
functor from an index category which is
usually finite onto another category
which is usually not finite so it's a
way of sort of parameterizing um
infinite classes of morphisms and
objects by finite numbers of objects
amorphisms that's formerly that's what
that's what a diagram is showing and so
a lot of category theoretical
constructions like products co-products
push outs pullbacks equalizers limits
code limits all these things are defined
over diagrams and therefore require an a
priori notion of functors um
so maybe i can show a few of those just
to give some yeah interesting motivating
examples
so
let me show something like abstract
product uh so this will take a list of
objects
x and y
i have a feeling the name abstract
product is not going to be one that can
make it but that's a different maybe i
don't know
i can i'm open to other names product
category
uh product category is something else a
product category is a cartesian product
of categories um this is this would be
more like categorical product which is
something different
okay
um okay
but okay so you can see so this is the
labeled graph version of that but what
is also interesting is the universal
full location graph and let me also show
you universal reduced label graph and
then i'll explain what's going on
uh okay so a a um
a categorical product is effectively a
generalization of lots of different
kinds of products things like cartesian
products of sets direct products of
groups
cartesian products of topological spaces
etc
so uh probably the easiest way to see
what's going on is if we look at this
universal reduced labeled graph you can
see we fed it two objects and and which
were x and y and we've got this new
object x
which is x times y or the product of x
and y
um
and this is defined to be in effect the
most general object that sort of um that
could be thought of as being a product
of x and y and the way you can read that
off from this diagram is with okay okay
um
let me think of a way to explain this
okay probably the easiest way to think
about this is if you think about
every object as being a set and every
arrow is being a set inclusion map
so you can see so so now you can see
this x times y is just going to be uh
the um
it's just going to be the intersection
of x and y because you're saying x times
y is a subset of x and x times y is a
subset of y and what this dashed line
here is doing is it's indicating a
universal property it's saying any other
um
actually let's show the full
universal labels graph
it's saying any other object
uh okay
i've just realized x x and y was a bad
choice of name y is the i'm using y to
indicate the additional object let me
let me do x1 and x2 i'll fix that in a
later version um but okay so what this
is saying is that any other object y
such that there exists some an arrow f1
from y to x1 and arrow f2 from y to x2
such that this diagram commutes it will
be the case that there is a unique
morphism f which is given by this dashed
line from y to x1 times x2
so it's telling us that not only is x1
times x2 a subset of x1 and a subset of
x2 it's telling us that it is in effect
the largest subset of x1 and x2 because
if you had any other set y that was a
subset of x one times x two then that
subset wouldn't
sorry that was a that was a subset of x
one and a subset of x two it would in
turn be a subset of x one times x two
so this universal property is a way of
saying it's the it's the largest
canonical uh set that contain that that
is contained in both x1 and x2 if that
makes sense
um
so
it's in that regard that you can think
of a categorical product as being
effectively a gen you know it's it's the
general construction of which uh direct
products cartesian products uh
topological products etc are all special
cases
and
how does it relate to type products and
type theory is it related in any way yes
yeah absolutely
so i mean
all of category theory is deeply related
to type theory right because in effect
if you if you think of every object as
being a type and every function as being
a
function that's you know bool arrow bool
or bool arrow into whatever
then a category is just a specification
of a type semantics and then these are
exactly um
product types
okay
uh and so so you know if you were to
think about this in like i don't know a
typed imperative language or something
pi 1 and pi 2 these projection maps
would be essentially
getter functions that you would you've
got a product x1 a product type x1 x2
and you've got a get that returns
something of type x1 you've got another
get that returned something of type x2
hey christopher is all this stuff
relevant for visualizing
uh you know complicated compound types
in the compiler
i don't think so
i don't think there's like i think that
the types in the compiler are
realistically not nearly this
complicated
okay even when they're generated
automatically
yeah
okay
all right okay
right and you know and so you could take
products of you know arbitrarily many
things you get a more complicated
looking universal property which reduces
in some nice way uh hang on if i wanted
to i could get
let me just
if i show something like this
and that's something like this so a code
product
yeah okay go on well a co-product which
is just the dual concept to a product is
now effectively
you know again essentially you can think
of this as a generalization of a direct
sum of modules or vector spaces or a
disjoint union of sets or
topological spaces or you know a free
product of groups or something like that
so uh what this is saying now is okay
let's go with the two objects case
so this is now saying so x1
sum this is often called a categorical
sum or or coprolite so it's saying x1
sum x the sum of x1 and x2
is defined so that uh there's an
inclusion map from x1 to
x1 to that and an inclusion max map from
x2 to that and again it satisfies the
universal property so in exactly the
same way if you think about this now in
terms of sets and inclusions you're
saying
x1 sum x2 is such that x1 is a subset of
it and x2 is a subset of it and it's
somehow the smallest set such that both
such that x1 is a subset and x2 is a
subset because if there were any other
set y such that x1 were a subset of y
and x2 were a subset of y then x1 sum x2
would be a subset of y
um and so it's in that sense that we can
say this is sort of a direct
generalization of the disjoint union of
sets
or in that space or direct sum of
modules or whatever um
and again it's it's sort of the the the
power of this lies in this universal
property here and so because
you know in effect this is you this is
quantifying over all objects and
morphism saying any object y such that
there exists an f1 from x1 to y and then
f2 from x2 to y there must exist a
unique morphism f from x1 sum x2 to y
um and so because these are universally
quantified things we can embed something
like this in a larger category so i can
say
something like co-products
universal uh
what i want to say universal code
product category i think i might have to
double check
yeah it's that so then this will return
an abstract category object if i had
them if if
i wanted to i could embed this code
product in some larger category that
contained an object x1 and object x2 and
it would it would handle this kind of
universal quantification over morphisms
for me
um
but okay so let me let me uh then talk
about some some general
the reason i'm introducing these
concepts is both to show the power of
these um these universal
uh properties which are sort of fairly
fundamental in category theory and also
to build up intuition for abstract limit
and abstract code limit which are uh
very very general class effectively
super functions that encompass a load of
other stuff because limits and code
limits are so fundamental uh but they
kind of don't make any sense unless you
motivate them with a bunch of examples
first okay hold on can we get a basic
architecture here so we've got these
abstract categories which are these
finite category things and we have a
whole bunch of operations on them
that
are
building up i mean these these products
are building up sort of products of
objects and things and maybe we'll have
um
uh you know there are various other
kinds of constructions that
build up bigger kinds of categories and
so on
where is there some moment where we're
going to be starting to do
very non-trivial computations with these
or is it largely building up essentially
the bureaucracy of categories which is
highly useful but i'm go ahead well
so most of this is building up the
bureaucracy but again it depends what
you mean by non-trivial computation so
something like computing you know doing
effectively diagrammatic theorem proving
which is what we were doing before with
commutative diagram
um in effect you could argue that is
non-trivial computation yeah sure i mean
people spend all kinds of you know all
kinds of exercises and books about you
know arrow chasing and things like this
right diagram chasing exactly um and so
it
it really depends what you mean i mean i
would argue for instance that the the
functions like abstract limit are doing
also very non-trivial computation okay
well that's
yeah
but
again but like i don't know it's at some
level the
the distinction between what is
bureaucracy and what is non-trivial is a
bit blurred
i understand i understand but so
in terms of kind of
relating for example the physics project
kinds of things
the big versions of this where things
aren't explicitly named will end up
being more like sort of physics project
stories is that true
sure sure and you know for instance uh
you know okay once you've got
the reason i focus so heavily on
bureaucracy is that once you've got the
bureaucracy down everything else becomes
quite easy so you know for instance once
you've got a good design for abstract
functor representing something like a
you know compact closed symmetric
monodole category which our multi-system
which a multi-way system is
um becomes really easy because because
the monoidal structure is just an
abstract functor on a product category
that satisfies certain coherence
conditions the dagger structure is just
a an evolutive functor from a category
onto its opposite category uh the
compact structure is just a you know a
pair of sort of distinguished morphisms
etc so representing these kind of more
sophisticated objects becomes really
easy once you've got the bureaucracy
um does that represent a general marker
go ahead
what you were saying for the different
representations in the physics project
those are finite things or
uh so like these are
most of the time they would not be
finite um so you know most multi-way
systems don't
because most computations don't
terminate most multi-way systems are not
finite graphs
but so in this framework
you don't have a generator of multi-wave
systems you have a way of
explicitly giving a multi-way system
as writing it not as a graph as we might
normally write it
but as a category specification is that
correct
right although i mean there's no reason
in principle why you couldn't generate
categories from rules it's just that
that's not currently supported and you
know for instance in in the in the type
theory and functional programming
context that's exactly what one does
right one one specifies a set of type
constructors
and one gets a category out
yes although one expects to be using
those by hand one doesn't expect to have
a generator
thing that is just churning out
you know complicated types
uh well in independent type theory you
can you can do that right you can have a
higher inductive type that is exactly a
generator of complicated types
right
and you know one of the things that came
out of the sort of uh connection with
homotopy type theory that xexus and i
worked on is that you know there is this
nice correspondence between higher
inductive types and multi-way systems
that have differing levels of completion
okay this
that this is good by by having this
explicit form of category theory it will
be easier for people like me to
understand that
right right in effect all that's all
that's doing is it's saying that there
is a because of essentially curry howard
isomorphism reasons there is a
one-to-one correspondence between
multi-wave rules and type constructors
and the resulting multi-way systems that
you get out are exactly or are
themselves in one-to-one correspondence
with the symmetric minor categories you
would have got from those type
constructors
um
okay that's kind of what and then and
then these various properties
so for a given multi-way system
generated by a particular let's say
string rewriting rule you can start
asking all these kinds of you know
uh you know all these different
properties of the of categories you
could ask for those essentially
multi-way graphs
right right exactly uh which which you
know in again in the language of menoir
category theory the multi-way evolution
graphs are really string diagrams
um and so once you have symmetric manual
categories you could request out the
string diagrams and you would get
essentially something that's trivially
interconvertible with a multi-way system
but nevertheless these other properties
of categories you would also be able to
ask about the multi-race system
right right so you could ask for
instance is there an inverse you know
are there left and right inverses for a
particular rule application
or something that would be you know the
analog of retractions and sections
cool okay all right so
um
how far do we have to go to get to the
symmetric one idle category business how
many more layers of of
concepts do we have to have
unfortunately quite a few um i mean but
so i i wasn't focusing too much i mean
there is a prototype of you know
symmetric minor categories and things in
in here but given that as i say that
once you've got a notion of functors and
you've got a notion of product
categories those things are kind of
trivial i've been focusing much more on
the constructions of
essentially more fundamental categorical
constructs fair enough
so uh yeah okay so for instance what i
wanted to show was okay you can
generally you could take these um
uh
you can take things like products and
co-products and you can generalize them
a bit and you can get things like
pullbacks and push outs so if i take let
me say abstract co-span
so a closed band is just a pair of
morphisms that have a common codomain so
if i say something like that
f
g
span
uh so then i could say um
oh no wait
uh wait what do i want to do i want to
say
hang on
uh what do i want oh no i what i want is
pull back
for labeled graph there we go
um
what the hell is that what is a pullback
right okay so in effect a pullback you
can think of as being a uh
a generalization of the concept of a
categorical product so again maybe if i
show
don't you think of it as a substitution
i don't know though i might understand
it but i don't see that yet i think i
think it is basically a substitute i
mean it's a it's one where you replace
the innermost thing basically
jonathan
right okay so yeah no that is that is a
useful way to think about it so
um okay the the concept originally comes
from from topology and homological
algebra and and you know the concept of
fiber
or geometry differential geometry or
from differential geometry but yeah one
also has a concept of fiber products um
but in a sense in a purely structural
graph theoretic way you can think about
it as being just
category no wait
sorry i forget exactly what the syntax
is
um you have properties if you say
co-span uh no i i i haven't implemented
properties for this yet unfortunately
uh
oh whatever no never mind there is a way
to extract the coastline category but
that was but it doesn't really matter
what roughly is this
right okay so so here you've got a span
right you've also you've got a co-span
you've got an arrow from x to z and
you've got an arrow from white as ed
the co-span is sort of the
the minimal
set of okay the okay the way you can
think about the pullback of that cospan
is that it's the minimal set of objects
and arrows you would need to add to make
this into a commutative square so you
can see what we've done is we've added
an object p and a pair of morphisms p1
p2 from p to p going from uh p1 going
from p to x and p2 going from p to y
uh and if i say and this
um square is commutative because if i
now ask for the reduced labeled graph
you can see that by default f compose p1
and g compose p2 are are equivalenced
and this thing is universal so if i ask
for its universal pullback or i ask for
its universal reduced
labeled graph what does universal mean
well so again it's it's it's this
concept of universal properties that we
already saw in products and co-products
so what you're saying is so this object
p completes this commutative square but
moreover it's the most general object
that completes the commutative square
because any other object q
uh that
such that there exists an arrow from
an arrow q1 from q to x and an arrow q2
from q to y it is necessarily the case
that there is a unique morphism u from
q2p that forces this diagram to commute
by the way
from a design point of view
you are generating variables with sort
of special names with wild abandon here
right right okay so um that's a good
point uh so right now
in order to avoid you know name clashes
and things uh okay so
okay a couple of points on that one is
that as you as we saw already with
things like abstract functor and
abstract category where you've got you
know symbols for identities and symbols
for composition or whatever like all of
these things are modifiable so if you
want to change the name of the
object that appears in the pullback you
could change it from p to whatever um
the other thing to note is that right
now i know you'll probably think this is
a hack but i
i don't know whether it's more or less
of a hack than using formal very than
using formal symbols but right now the
generated things are always strings to
avoid um you're a big string enthusiast
you know untangling the strings to put
it to to kind of make the pun in
multi-way system has got to be a huge
you know undertaking here but yes i i
right i mean look we've got a whole
class of these things like same thing
with axiomatic theory we've got all
these things which are sort of formal
objects
that have to be generated they have
names they're still used elsewhere i
think it remains a bit of a tangle what
to do with all of this
and
what is the is there a fundamental
problem with just like unique symbols
and things
well there is in terms of displaying it
it's ghastly
well maybe we could have something like
unique but where it makes
let me think i mean in a similar way to
how we have the the dotted symbols
well i'm thinking if there's somehow we
could have symbols that are like
displayed
displayed in a nicer way even if they
have some crazy uuid like name well i
think that's probably the right thing to
do yes i think that's probably the right
thing which which by the way i mean
right i mean we could have something
like unique maybe i mean yeah i mean we
could have like a version of unique that
uh puts things into some special context
in which their names are you know and
the front end knows that if it's a
symbol from this context to light its
name which by the way would solve
another problem with unique right now
which is that unique creates things in
global
which is a problem because if you have
like internal code and you call unique
then you're creating a bunch of global
symbols as opposed to symbols in some
internal private context that's a good
idea can we move that can somebody take
a note of that and let's do that talk
about the next i'll be meeting
there's a special context for unique
symbols
which
break nothing it should break nothing to
change that even for the unique function
unless somebody has depended on in some
crazy way
okay please onward jonathan doesn't your
code clear global
what
yeah
i'm sure your code just do clear global
backtick star
why what
no i'm kidding
okay
okay
all right a co-span so we have some
vague understanding of what co-span is
well i still didn't get the intuition
for what a pullback is
right i mean like coast bands are easy
right cospans are just you know
pairs of things that have the same
co-domain so
a pullback so you could okay you can see
that in a sense a pullback is just the
same as a product but we've got this
additional
we've got an additional object
so um
you can see that in effect p
is just like
you know if you think about this in
terms of um sets and set inclusions
again we've got
uh two sets x and y that are themselves
subsets of some additional set z
and p is in effect the the largest set
that is such that p is a subset of x and
p is a subset of y yeah right
why do we care i mean so so what's the
intuition i mean what
somebody said substitute two sets what's
that
that's the intersection of two sets
so just just as the product is a
generalization of the of set
intersection
for the reasons we stated before
uh a pullback is a generalization of a
product
okay
it encompasses it so in the special case
where either z doesn't you
if you got rid of f g and z or you just
have z be trivial then you'd recover
exactly a product
but in effect you can think of this as
being like a product with an additional
gluing transformation
that's going to be the right intuition
for it and similarly a push out of a
span which is the dual notion is
effectively like a disjoint union with a
gluing operation so it's it is itself a
generalization of a categorical
co-product so if i take abstract
if i say this is abstract span
and i say push out
is the correspondence of names to push
out rewriting in graphs coincidental or
is there some connection
no i mean what do you mean
they are they are pushouts categorical
graph rewriting deals with
single push outs and double push outs so
uh in fact i can show you that right so
um
i mean this is this was the work done by
hartmut eric and people like that back
in sort of the 19
i think 1980s was when this you know
this deep connection between
compositionality and algebraic graph
rewriting was sort of really stunning
what is algebraic graph rewriting
well so graph is you know treating graph
rewriting rules as abstract algebraic
structures which then allows you to use
category theory on them so in uh in
compositional and algebraic graph
rewriting uh your spat so every every
graph rewriting rule is a span
uh
where you have um that goes from an
interface graph
k to the left hand side of a rule and
the interface and um an interface graph
to the right-hand side of the rule
oh boy and then okay yep
right so so this would be called a graph
production or a or a graph rewriting
rule so you can think so the intuition
for this is so uh okay
right so the intuition for this is that
l is
l all the objects here are graphs we're
we're working in the category of graphs
l is the left hand side of the rule r is
the right hand side of the rule and k is
the index graph which you can think of
as being sort of invariant sub graph
that's that's left over when you apply
this rule so um then the then in dpr
which is kind of the most general form
of graphene writing that's currently
known what you're doing is you're
exactly applying a push out square and a
push out complement square of this span
the push out square the responsibility
of the push-up squares it takes a graph
g
uh and it the intuition is it extracts
out a sub graph of uh that's isomorphic
to l and leaves essentially dangling
edges uh that are given by the index
graph and then the push out complement
square glues in to this index graph you
know to the invariant subgraph uh a
graph isomorphic to r and so so it's
it's it's encoding these two steps the
so the the two push-out diagrams that
are glued together are encoding these
two steps that one does in the sort of
general form of graph rewriting
um and so yeah as you
undoubtedly know that you know the sort
of the two standard versions are spo
which is where you're just where
everything is done with a single push
out of a single span
um and dpo where you also have an
injective morphism from g to l
um and you do two push outs of that
um
so anyway so
and so there's there would be a nice i
prefer my description in terms of hairs
and things it's more
much it's uh more mundane but yes this
is this is lovely well the hairs are
exactly i mean
k is a formalization of your concept of
hairs yes right
anyway so one nice thing is that if we
do have a wolfram language
implementation of graph rewriting at
some point uh this would integrate quite
nicely with that that there should be
some nice way of of getting out you know
the span that corresponds to a given
rule the injective monomorphism that the
sorry the monomorphism corresponds to a
given uh you know to a given graph match
um and the double push out the
correspond to a given event
know all of those things are you know
would be extractable for instance from a
wolfram model multi-way system
um
yes
or even a regular warfare model right
not not even the multi-weight case
uh sure sure um
[Music]
if i don't know because the event
specification for wolf model is not
quite as rich as the event specification
for multi-way systems i understand that
right
for it but um
but yeah in principle yes
and that's that's a piece of unification
that we still need to talk about about
graph rewriting
in
physics project versus graph theory
versus chemistry et cetera okay but
let's go back to category theory here
um right okay so um what i'm doing is
i'm trying to show a bunch of examples
of
of limits and co-limits to kind of
motivate why you need this
generalization so as just the last
example of that let me show things like
equalizers and co-equalizers i'm sorry
where did you show a limit did you i
haven't yet right because the problem is
if i just show a limit it'll be utterly
incomprehensible if you haven't seen one
before okay
so this is why i'm showing lots of
motivating cases
so an equalizer if we if we start with
two um let's say x
so we start from with a pair of
morphisms between the the same
two objects
and i say um
so the intuition behind an equalizer is
that it's essentially a generalization
of the set of solutions to an equation
so um well in abstract algebra it's
exactly you know the the sort of the
difference kernel of two functions
so uh
the idea here is you've got a pair of uh
morphisms which you can think of as
being like functions from x to y
and we we've got this we've got this
arrow eek and this object e that we're
introducing um and we're saying uh the
the um f compose that
uh the hang on if i take
the reduced version of this
you can see we're imposing that f
compose eq is equal to g compose so
we've collapsed that to just a single
edge so in effect you can think of this
equalizer this pair given by the object
e and the arrow
as being the uh a generalization of the
solution set of the of the you know the
the set of uh morphisms for which f and
g are equal or the set of values for
which f and g are equal
um so
i completely don't okay so the point is
that i see that single e is mapping both
to the x and to the y
i don't understand that to say that
again it's the second
you've got an equalizer in ordinary
algebra right so you've got two
functions f and g they're functions on
sets say uh the equalizer is just the
set of elements x such that f of x
equals g of x in y right okay
um so
all we're doing here is we're saying
f compose equals g compose
well that's
just you know that's saying if we apply
f to e we get the same thing as if we
apply g to e so e
is analogous to the set of elements
for which
uh f of x equals g of x
so this pair e eq in the case of
functions on sets would is actually
contains e restricts us
sort of
cuts down the x
basically
right right exactly and so
you know f f and g is going to behave
the same that's that's that's its role
and again we have a universal property
that's telling us something
that's effectively telling us the e e is
kind of the the is the unique pair for
all the sort of canonical pair for which
this works that any other object o and
paramorphisms you know m and n that you
could have introduced that would have
done the same thing uh will have the
property that there's a unique morphism
from o to e
so
eq is
a solution somehow
uh in effect or what's the i mean what's
the goal where are we heading i don't
know where we're heading
well i mean so again like the the idea
is to have something which in the
particular for the case of set would
give you exactly an equalizer in the
standard algebraic sense so
you know amorphism
you know o to
x say equalizes f and g if it's the case
that f compose m equals g compose m
and so e
or eq here is is by by this universal
property the most general equalizer of f
and g
but we don't want to find eq we don't we
don't we're not trying to find it or
anything
well again if you were doing a universal
algebra computation you you would right
because what you'd um so if you had a
category with with different kernels so
if you're in some some category where
you can do universal algebra
then the object e gives you the ordinary
notion of an equalizer and equals the
inclusion function of e into x
so it's the function that specifies e as
a subset of x
i see i see i see i see specifies e
is the subset of x
for which
f of x equals g of x is that right
which is which is exactly what f compose
equals g composite means
i get it okay i get it finally so eq is
a is a
e is the subset of x
which is
sort of yeah okay
right so this is the minimal set of
equations necessary to define a equal an
equalizer and this is the minimal set of
equations necessary to specify the
universal property that says this is the
sort of canonical equalizer it's the
equalizer so that any other equalizer
has a unique it has a unique injection
into e
okay
and i should say i should mention that
obviously
you know uh in addition to doing the
just like before with you know groupoid
and commutativity and so on uh in
addition to reasoning directly over the
graphs you can always request out sort
of algebraic form of what's going on so
you could ask you know what are the uh
if i said span you know universal push
out equations or something over here it
would give me the minimal set of
equations necessary to define the
universal property of this push out
square by the way i assume these
equations can be fed into the theorem
which will then do useful things with
them yes yeah exactly
exactly
um
and you know in effect because you know
it's it's really quite nice the fact
that uh you know category theory in some
sense can be large parts of it can be
reduced to universal algebra and
obviously the theorem proven knows how
to deal with universal algebra so
you know
i'm kind of viewing this framework in
part as being the skeleton of a general
you know category theory type theory
type uh you know
style improver
um
that bill by the way i mean an axiomatic
theory do we have category theory as one
of the theories so that at least with
whatever we choose as the final version
of the dot circle dot here uh has has
the axioms of that in
i don't think so so okay unless it's
been implemented since i since i was
working on it i don't think we do
um the reason being i i remember we
initially discussed this
um and then this is years ago now and
you steven made some cryptic comment
that slightly worried me which is that
you claimed that saunders maclean
claimed that category theory is not an
axiomatic theory
which seems to be nonsense which which
well i thought at the time was nonsense
but i didn't want to i was
okay okay
well i don't know i mean i it was a very
distinct claim so it was uh i think it
may have more have a more philosophical
character than we're giving it credit
for in terms of the actual structure
here
but i mean like there certainly is no
limitation to just having because you
know it's not that dissimilar to say
combinator axioms right it's just giving
you axioms of function composition and
identity yes what are the central
groupoid axioms and how they relate to
the groupoids we're talking about here
totally unrelated
does mana know what these are
i i don't know how they're related to
group groupoids and category theory now
okay all right it's a mystery
something something to figure out
okay apparently a
okay i'm
i've never heard of a central groupoid
before i've i found one paper by don
knuth from 1970 that seems to be about
them
and maybe the name groupoid means
something completely different from what
it means in category theory
i don't know yeah okay all right
detangling
okay onward
right so what i wanted to show now
was the fact that all of these different
constructions that seem quite disparate
are all
essentially special cases of this very
very general construction in some sense
possibly the most general construction
in category theory which is the notion
of a limit
so
if i take
uh let's actually begin with with a
really simple case
just
um
illustrate what's going on
so this is my category i've just got a
single arrow in it
and if i now say abstract limit
this notebook is getting slightly slow
but oh well
uh i get this thing
so now i can say
i have to say limit full label graph now
i can just say that right okay so this
thing here is what's called and i should
say so f is a functor but but this could
be and so right now it's just symbolic
this could be any func i could call it
funk or something if i wanted to and i
get something slightly different but
let's keep it as f capital f
so this thing here is called a cone
um it's commutative as with most things
so if i call reduced it would get rid of
that multi-edge
um so what this is saying is uh
the the notion of a cone is given by
it's
you can think of it as in terms of
you've got a distinguished object l
and you've got uh
l is mapping to f of x and f of y by
these morphisms five x five
phi phi sub x phi y for every morphism f
of f that maps from f x to f of y
right so if i had another morphism in
here
say that goes from y to z
if i took the limit of that i'd get a
slightly more complicated looking cone
um what the heck why is it called a
limit
well this is just a cone so far the the
definition of a limit is a cone with
we're satisfying a universal property so
um
if i said now uh universal
labeled graph
okay
we get this universal property so this
is now saying that this that any other
any other cone that you could so l is
the l phi x phi y is our initial cone
and this is now saying that any other
cone n
uh psi x psi y must uniquely factor
through l so in a sense l is again just
you know just like the universal
properties we saw before we're saying
that l is somehow the kind of canonical
cone
and so so it's a when when a cone is
universal when every other cone factors
through
l or l phi then we call l phi a limit
and that's what's going on here
um and so again as again as with most
things in category theory you know the
reason it's called a limit is similar to
the reason it's called a push out or a
pullback because these in the particular
case of topology where they or algebraic
topology where they emerged they are
topological limits so a uh
when you formalize your functor as a
filter then uh and you know your objects
are topological spaces then the limit of
that filter is exactly the categorical
limit of the corresponding functor
um
this is a bit hard to follow for me
so so as i say the limits are hard to
understand because they seem so abstract
um but
the the the thing to realize is that
basically everything that you everything
we've do
everything we've just all the
constructions we've seen are special
cases of limits or co-limits they're
dual so to see that for instance let me
take the example of products so if i
said abstract so a
um you can think of a product as being a
limit taken over a discrete category
where discrete category is one that has
objects but no morphosums so let me
define a discrete category
let's say x1 x2
and it has no arrows
so that's our initial category
and if i now say abstract limit of that
i get the limit of that category
that's the labeled graph and this is the
universal property
and so you can see immediately that this
is exactly the same as the categorical
product that we saw before
so if i take
okay so in the case where it had four
elements it would look like this i can
see that directly if i go
change this to be
a discrete category with four objects
and i would get
i would recover precisely the definition
of a product so it's in that sense that
a
we say a limit as a
that a a product is just a limit over a
discrete category
in exactly the same way you could say a
uh a pullback is just a limit over a
co-span in other words a limit over a
category that has
two arrows or a diagram that has two
arrows with a common codomain so if i
say f
that
and i take a limit over this
now i get precisely again the definition
with some relabeling i get precisely the
definition of a pullback
um
or with a with an equal i would say
equalizers those are special cases of
limits as well right and an equalizer
for us is just if we say
so
in some senses there's a code versus
data play that is this limit thing is
taking what you might thought of but
have thought of as data that is the
structure of some category and it is
saying somehow that it is encoding
certain operations that you've given
names to before as being things that you
get by applying this kind of universal
thing
this limit thing to
the structure of a category is that a
reasonable way to think about it and i
mean if you take a more ornate category
well you get something that is a
generalization of you know push-outs or
something
right right yeah no exactly so uh you
know so um
push-outs themselves are special cases
of co-limits obviously the the duel of
limits but yeah if you took a co-limit
of a more comp so a push-out is a
co-limit of a span of a diagram that has
two arrows with a common domain if you
took a co-limit of some more arbitrary
you know some more general ornate
diagram you'd get something that was
some some vast generalization of a push
out
but so in some sense this is sort of a
higher order function type idea
it's a it's a
well the these the the point is these
are all high okay
so i agree with the sentiment of what
you're saying
so these are all high level functions
right because they're defined by
universal property even even the
simplest case even something like a
product is like a high level function
because you're defined by universal
property you're saying this is an
operation and all other operations are
sort of special cases all other
operations that with the same arguments
are sub uh special cases of this
operation that's what that universal
property is telling you then the limit
is the generalization of all of those
where you're saying even that operation
is as you know is a special case of
this
very very general operation which is
taking a limit
um although presumably there's a family
of those things and you could go and do
the next level of this
uh no so um
limits that okay there are some pretty
fundamental theorems uh that effectively
tell you limits are like
universal somehow yeah as high as you
can go in this abstraction tower that
any other universal property or any
other operation that you could define by
means of a universal property can in
turn be defined in terms of limits and
co-limits so they yeah there's some
there's something akin to computational
universality that's going on here
that's interesting
i mean it's
so in other words it's ingesting a
category
and it is
it's producing this other thing okay
that's interesting well okay don't fully
understand but yes
it's
really it's ingesting an index category
and a functor and it's outputting
something more complicated it's
outputting because these these diagrams
involving universal properties are not
themselves categories they're really
rules for general they're sort of
category schemas right
um
because this is some universal
quantifier over all possible morphisms
um
that's why it doesn't this is why the
thing has dashed lines in it because it
has these universal properties
so wait a minute
you're saying
okay i i get it so it's a category
schema
that has an arbitrary where where you as
a in some sense a quantified over or
it's a
it's a kind of a um
so it's n uh psi x and psi y are
quantified over you're saying for any
object n
and any object and any morphism psi x
from n to f of x and any any morphism
psi y from n to f of y it is the case
that this
there is a morphism from n to l that is
unique and that's given by this thing
here
and why is that the thing that gets to
be dotted i mean how do you know that
those things are quantified over from
this diagram how do you know what's
quantified over
just because this is the standard
notation for universal properties
um i understand but you said that psi
and something else there were being
quantified over how do i tell that from
looking at the diagram i mean you know
something's looking in the diagram it's
qualify over the left-hand side
and all of the edges from it
right right but there's nothing
i agree okay arguably there should be
some kind of in these
in these pictures that are effectively
showing you category schemas
um there should be some kind of tagging
that says which things are you know
one degree of freedom that we obviously
have that people
uh have not traditionally have is we can
use colors for things right right um no
absolutely that would be nice so i mean
i should mention the only reason i don't
show that is precisely because that's
not
conventionally how these things are
represented but i mean color is a nice
sort of piece of metadata we can add in
that would be you know some eerie color
could represent the quantified version
the the things that are being quantified
over that are not
um
right so like you know if i show you
like okay the wikipedia page for limit
for instance has a diagram of exactly
this form you've got an l an f of x and
f of y and f of f of phi x phi y psi x
psi y
um and it's it's only in the text that
it says you know for every other cone
you're quantifying over n and psi but
that's not actually indicated in in this
picture right so we need a notation we
need a visual notation for representing
that maybe it's gray lines maybe it's i
don't know what
maybe it's some
uh okay
all right onward
right okay so um
okay that's
uh because abstract so abstract limit
abstract code limits do loads of stuff
right there they're very very powerful
functions um
most of the other constructions the
things that let you build symmetric
monado categories dagger categories all
those other things can be generated
using the functionality that i've
already shown
okay
so maybe i should now
get to at least some of the questions
that i that i kind of wanted to
ask design-wise before you know before i
proceed and kind of building off the
stuff that's already here i wanted
there's a bunch of stuff that i wanted
to check just kind of made sense from a
design standpoint
i would say that the first thing is for
goodness sake let's show this to the
graphic design folk i think we can make
these things look nicer
and i also wonder from a uh the graph
theory point of view um graph
rendering point of view there's a bunch
of places here where you're not where
there seems to be an unnecessary kind of
exclusion zone around the label
like the n's and l's there they have a
big exclusion zone
and i think look
go ahead
uh that's partly by design um because if
you just use default graph rendering you
get something that's quite hard to read
um okay
i suspect that that exclusion zone if
there was a light gray background or
something in that exclusion zone the
picture will look better
okay
okay i mean i think a little bit of
experimenting with that is probably
worthwhile but are you happy with the
way that the graph
layout
i mean i think the graph layout looks
pretty nice in general here
i mean there's no issues
no it's a you can see
i i've defaulted to using left to right
like you know layout because that just
seems like the most natural it you know
it it's nice to have all the arrows
going in one direction right so so this
is just using how did you do that how
did you do the graph layout there just
lay a diagraph you know it's using a
layer diagraph embedding with
orientation left to right
okay roger do you have any comments on
that
no i mean that makes perfect sense to me
i mean
that's the option and also for
readability i think at least
for us to read left to right
that seems natural
but but now layer digraph does it get
confused when you have loops
yeah
and i think we need to look at layered
digraphs more because we've had an awful
lot of things and nick has run into this
as well
where
there are loops and it may not do the i
mean they're loops and it's not uniquely
defined and it may or may not do the
most sensible thing
yeah
i mean
if there is loops there is it's not a um
i know it's not a layered diagraph right
i understand that but the question is
what since we oftentimes have things
that we want to lay out in some kind of
layered way
how should we do that
and i think
we should probably get some meeting
about layered digraph we probably get a
bunch of examples from nick and jonathan
and others of things with loops
that were it was a question of how it
should lay them out i mean it doesn't do
badly it does surprisingly decently but
i think it'd be worth understanding i
don't think any of us understand how
much freedom there is in laying it out
when there are loops
if you get what i'm saying
and we may want to have some extra
controls for some of these cases where
we're trying to use them for you know
automatically building diagrams
right
all right universal limit equations oh
my god
just a thing that i i remembered so uh
given we were talking about having good
rendering for for um
uh
you know for um
universal quantification it would also
make sense i mean it doesn't do this
right now but if we're going to have
explicit quantification over arrows and
objects then when you request out say
the the equations that define the
universal property then these things
should have universal quantifier
arguably should have universal
quantifiers in them so that they could
be directly fed into the theorem i would
think they should have yeah i would
think they absolutely should have i
can't see why they wouldn't have in that
case
um
right so most of the time when you get
out a set of equations it would be just
the set of equations
um like for groupoid equations or
commutative diagram equations or
whatever but for uh anything defined by
universal property they would actually
have universal quantifiers on them right
i mean one thing that we still need to
probably think through more that's
probably missing information there like
like what is it quantified over
well yes you have to give that i mean
one thing that is still a bit confusing
for us is the relationship between
pattern variables and universal
quantifiers
that's a different set of issues okay in
any case
um
so all right jonathan your your set of
questions here right right okay so so a
few things just
fairly mundane sanity check things so uh
we were discussing before that or at
least it seemed to be the case in our
discussions earlier that we kind of
agreed just having property names like
this is not really
rich enough to do a lot of the things
you would want to do
so
i know in some way you can't just have
property names with and we've got plenty
of functions that have decorated
property names
right right okay but so is it is that
what we want or do we want to have a
separate function that just takes a
category and says uh you know give me
a list of retractions or
you know something i don't know it's a
question of how much we want to bite the
bullets and go full category theory
because i mean we'll end up with 30
functions to deal with category theory
presumably if we do that
i mean everybody got an opinion
right it would be more consistent with
graphs to to have a million functions
but i i don't know how desirable that is
i mean it really depends on how
seriously we're going to be able to take
category theory as a core feature of the
system
i mean if we can really make it
interoperate with practical things it
makes sense
sorry i mean the thing is i think
they're just there's so many more
functions where you know oh this random
function with neural networks can return
a graph and and stuff like that then
they'll never be then they'll ever be
for categories
well that's the question
are there places in the existing system
okay in the existing system are there
places where we would say oh i wish we
could return a category from here
for example in the type analysis of the
compiler there might be places where you
say oh i wish we could return a category
is that true or is that complete
nonsense
um no i doubt it i mean there's there's
certainly nothing in the way that the
the type system is currently set up
you know okay where
categories show up next we just probably
return something but yeah right next
question is there a place where we'd
like to feed in a category
you know is there a function for which
it would be nice to say
oh if we could only feed in a category
that would be useful just like there are
functions where like for neural nets for
example the fact that we have graphs
is highly useful for being able to
construct a net graph
are there similar places where it's like
just feed in a category
any thoughts jonathan any other
well okay i can't i can only really talk
about the areas that
of the system i know well but in all i
think in all of those there are cases
where you would either where you might
want to input and or output categories
explain
well for you know we've already
discussed for things like graph
rewriting and multi-way systems and so
on
you know like multi-way systems are
interconvertible with symmetric monolith
categories uh graph rewritings us
rewriting rules are interconvertible
with spans of monomorphisms um you know
rewriting events are interconvertible
with double pushouts uh rewriting
matches into convertible with with uh
injective morphisms etc
um similarly in say the quantum
framework uh you know
specifications of
quantum circuits are interconvertible
with string diagrams for the node or
categories so again you there are cases
where you might want to input a category
or output a category for those
yeah theorem explain that one yeah well
you know if you had for instance right
our uh you know find equational proof is
currently working with a with an untyped
lambda calculus effectively
um but if we wanted to do something if
we wanted to have a theorem proving
framework that was more akin to
lean or agar or [ __ ] or something um
which was at least simply typed
then you know
there
perhaps unlike with the compiler there
you really do want to be able to
generate kind of arbitrarily decorated
types and functions between them which
are you know very well represented by
categories
um so what's the minimal thing just so i
understand what's the minimal thing that
our you know untyped
equational theorem prover cannot do
that a typed
lambda calculus theorem could do
well so for instance the thing that
roger was just referring to right of
like um what are you quantifying over
that's something we can't handle right
because precisely
for this reason that you're that you're
treating uh
the way fine equation or proof works is
you interconvert between universal
quantified variables and uh pattern
variables
um
right so we can't define we're
quantifying over integers or we're
quantifying over this is or that's
right right so you can say you know for
all x
x as an integer implies such and such
there's a way there are ways you can
hack it in certain cases but there are
more general kinds of theorems that
involve restrictions of of quantifiers
and things where that just doesn't work
isn't there isn't there a second
argument for for all where you can put
stuff like that
there is
like
three arguments
yeah yes
there is but that doesn't the other
restrictions on the quantification but
the the claim
what jonathan
you can say something like that i mean
you could say something that's that's
kind of close to that i mean
philosophically maybe it's not quite but
like for example in the compiler you
often do this with the for all type
which is similar to for all where you'd
say something like you know for all of x
comma
x is an element of
integers or something comma and then the
actual statement
and that that's sort of a way of just
saying that you're quantifying over the
integers
no no sure
absolutely universal like for all can
support this but a theorem proverb based
on an untyped lander calculus definitely
can't um
if you want even making it compatible
for instance with the wolfram language's
pattern system would require something
internally equivalent to simply typed
lambda calculus
well especially if you have slash
semicolons and things like that then
you're independent type theory and
you're going
you know you're often crazy land
right
and so whereas while the
execution semantics for
the untyped lambda calculus of the
theorem prover is basically trivial
uh if you wanted even to support simply
typed theorem proving it's sudden you
know now your execution semantics is
essentially given by some arbitrary
category um and
in some cases and actually in a lot of
cases it'd be nice if you could see what
that category is and manipulate it and
so on so so jonathan
did you perhaps mean that the thing
you're quantifying over is like a whole
category or something more
complex like that
uh no it's not not even
i mean you could you could have a
situation like that if you were if
you're
you know if your type structure is given
by the category cat i either category
all categories but no even something
much more mundane right so
if okay so you know
in our current theorem prover if you
want you know every function is untyped
essentially if you wanted to have
functions that were typed
then the then the
then in order to be able to do theorem
improving on them those functions have
to be you have to be able to compose
them
um and so then the the the the whole
type inference system would be given by
some arbitrary category
right where where every object is now a
type and every morphism is a
is a function
right but the type inferencing so why is
the compiler's type inferencing not a
category
or is it but just not very interestingly
so
types are objects in some category
yes and the compiler your you have
practical tools for generating new
objects
but you don't say plop down a whole
category and work with it
i see so it's a dynamically generated
category where you have type
constructors that are extending pieces
of you know extending out to new objects
but but that i mean that itself is a
category right it just may not be a
small category
yes that has arbitrary extensions to it
right right but but
yeah that was my point it's not that you
are passing around
finite like complete
set like categories as expressed here
right right but given a type construct
just i mean
if we ignore the practicalities of
actually
representing this
in a in a finite way given a given a set
of type constructors you will be able to
generate a category from it it just
well look it's the same story as
infinite lists infinite graphs all these
kinds of things we can imagine a
generator a schema but we don't have a
good way of representing those infinite
objects yet
right right and i'm sorry
until we have a sort of um standard way
of representing infinite lists of
associations and things we're kind of
limited to only dealing with finite
categories do we imagine i mean the
discrete calculus deals with infinite
lists all the time they're called
sequences
um that's what the whole thing is about
we sum over them we take products of
them we take differences
ratios
so difference equations to generate them
their infinite lists all the time
an interesting point
i mean
if you only quantify quantify over
objects or motion isn't it already an
infinite category if you have an ability
to quantify over there
right right so in something defined by
universal property you would be you you
would be writing down an explicit
schema but that's not that's not
defining an infinite category that's
defining an infinite class of categories
that's a different thing
okay but but
you can make a pattern of objects right
for an object like if you have a set
yeah sure
still can make some kind of pattern
right right just as you can have right i
mean this is you know it's the same
discussion we had about infinite lists
and infinite associations a while ago
right
but the problem is that they're just
there isn't a whole lot of
non-trivial computation that you can do
on those things and so
yeah you're going to be thrown into set
theory to the general set theory and so
on where
i have no idea whether i mean can i
theorem prove a just okay this is a
general knowledge question
theorems and set theory non-trivial
theorems and
uh you know set theory with infinite
sets and so on
can one do any of those automatically or
is that just totally hopeless
yeah absolutely but it requires a
stronger theorem than what we have
in particular in what way
well because so zfc
there are several ways you can formulate
it but it's either a first order theory
so find equational proof deals with
first order theories right
first order and equation
um
you can formulate zfc as a first order
theory with axiom schemas
which the theorem prover can't handle or
you can formulate it as a second order
theory without axiom schemas where you
can but one way you can quantify over
predicates
and although i implemented like a um
the minute you get into higher order
theorem proving i think you're out then
right right like you know hall and
isabelle and things you know can prove
non-trivial theorems instead of c i mean
health you know parts of forcing have
been formalized in in theory
improvements before do they have high
order
yes
yeah
and like you know with lean that's based
on higher inductive types you can you
can certainly simulate you know um
higher order logics
uh but you yeah you you need you need a
richer theorem than what we have right
now
but so we can't even do induction right
well we so with with find higher order
logic proof which is this prototype
thing that i made you you can do
induction um because you can formulate
it as a second or rather than
formulating as a first order axiom
schema you can formulate it as a second
order axiom uh but that isn't in system
um
it's not even the function repository
it's somewhere in the physics project
working folder
we should we should fish it out if
somebody from project management is
paying attention here let's fish that
out and make that a thing
um
okay but anyways
the
um
i mean hang on this is this is the thing
i mean i i mostly
i don't know why i didn't end up
submitting it so
in the end but um yeah this is a thing
which does i think i even have an
induction argument here yeah right
here's a higher order induction argument
let's get this in this looks nice i mean
at least then we have
a way to start discussing this issue all
right okay but this is
um right and i mean the way that this
works is kind of
algorithmically it's actually really
easy right all it's doing is anytime you
have a higher order uh axiom like this
one that quantifies over oh this is a
horrible thing right i think um
i had some meeting i think jose and i
had a meeting with adam strabonski about
how to deal with this problem but if you
put uh predicates in the quantifier then
then the front end automatically strips
them out unless you put it in hold form
um
why does the front end do it
you mean the front end
what
i mean
i think it's just that that implies
evaluates to true
uh
yes that that that may have been the
problem or i don't know i i thought yeah
there's no front end even this
no the front end is not this auto
evaluation in that case
right for the conditioner for all
does is for all hold anything
yes it's hold all custom evaluator
but for some reason it evaluates its
condition
custom evaluator means it can do
whatever it wants yes i know but in
particular it evaluates its condition
apparently
okay
we should look at that because that
doesn't seem like it's the right thing
okay but it's a separate issue okay
let's go back to jonathan
by the way the reason it's hold all this
to behave correctly is the scoping
concert i think everything else sort of
evaluates so you can't have science
okay
i should say that all this is what this
is doing is kind of algorithmically
trivial all that it's doing is it's
saying anytime you quantify over a
predicate
it will just get the list of all
predicates that appear in the axioms or
in the theorem
um and add a single first order
verge a first order instance of this
second order axiom one for each possible
predicate so it's just explicitly like
rolling out the um the predicate
um quantifier taking the axiom the axiom
schema and it's actually generating
an instance of the axiom for every for
every schema element is that right for
every schema value this isn't
technically a schema you'll write in
this case that it's
that this particular one is equivalent
to a first order axiom schema but this
is actually a second order axiom and in
general uh uh i mean
logicians get a bit finicky about this
but like i think it's the so um
everything that can be done with the
first order axiom schema can be done
with a second order axiom but not the
other way around
um i don't know not quite the same but
anyway yeah that's the basic
just unrolling the second order um all
right
so let's go back to the main design
question here so my feeling is that
right now we should have just properties
in the in the category theory framework
because i just think we're going to end
up with a zillion functions
i think that
you know let's start off with properties
it's not going to be incompatible you
know this is anyway it's going to be an
external you know package for now um
that will be part of its if it if it
lands as a system thing in the future
that will be part of its systemization
we'll be making those things into
functions that's right
sure although as we've discussed there
are particular things like for instance
abstract groupoid which i think we
agreed would make sense yes that's fine
that's fine i mean i think a modest
number of those uh you know mega
constructors so to speak make sense but
these properties
seem to me
uh questionable now in terms of
subtyping the retractions there were sub
sub casing the retractions thing i don't
know what almost standard anybody got an
opinion what the standard way to do that
with properties is is with the list
protractions comma and then something
else that seems to be a pretty common
pattern for how to do this
yep
i think that's what we generally since
comma f would give the list of
protractions of f
right something like that
but then should there be an operator
form
right should there be a thing which you
can apply to an a to amorphism and get
its list of attractions or is that too
yeah why not
why not i mean you've got to then give
given the category
look you could you could just have a
thing called retraction operator or
something
and then that returns a thing
that is a you know a function function
that when applied to that morphism it
it contains inside that function it
contains enough information to know you
know the structure of that category
and
then you feed it that particular
morphism and returns the retractions
right right i mean i don't know what you
call that i mean it's like retraction
uh
what the heck would it be called um
i'm not sure what it should be called uh
i mean it's the operator form of finding
the retractions
right
retractor
i don't know yeah i mean retraction
operator doesn't seem stupid
um it's okay i mean that that seems
confusing because of retraction being up
and you know everything's an operator in
this world
in this particular
zone
right um
let's see
uh
why you call it morphism retraction or
something i'm not sure because it
applies to
um
well i mean okay
maybe in this particular case right so
obviously retractions are those
morphisms that have uh left inverses
maybe you could say something maybe you
could just say left inverses or
something yeah that makes sense that
makes sense and gives either that either
you give it like that as an operator
form or it's list left in versus comma a
which would be the non-operator form of
left inverses of a
yeah i i i quite like that
okay all right let's just go on with
your list and then we probably should
wrap up soon here
okay there are some similar things again
about like essentially i'm i don't know
exactly what level of granularity these
functions should act at so for you know
abstract category right now is a huge
function um and it does a huge number of
things
and it's you know same with limit and
co-limits and it's a question of how
much of that functionality do we break
out into separate functions versus how
much of it do we keep in one function i
i would keep it in one function for now
because i think it's it's otherwise
we're going to end up with a much more
complicated jungle of design
okay okay so that'll
the basic philosophy is keep the minimal
number of functions
i think so i mean roger jose christopher
anybody anybody got opinion ian opinions
about that anybody here
is that a bad idea
well in general i think that we should
be careful with the names to not
preclude the
like implicit or infinite cases
i see
what you think either this should have a
name that definitely conveys that it's a
finite thing
or
we need to be sure that the design can
be expanded later if we want it to be
used for both
i was also kind of
curious why this
can't just be functions that act on
graphs
i think it shouldn't i mean
i think it takes graphs in some cases to
construct things i think is great
yeah no i think it should be its own
thing i think it's pretty conservative
design what you've done now with a few
functions
and
if we find lots of output more
applications
more ways than in which it sort of
connects to
all kinds of parts look i think we're
doing
you know this is the right thing
jonathan i think that just like with
multi-way system where you know it ends
up being a function with with
giant swiss army knife function okay
as it becomes a system function is going
to get cleaned up and simplified once we
know
you know now that we know something
about what's important about it and the
same thing will happen here so i think
this is the right way to do it
multi-unit system is a good analogy
right because it has
loads of properties obviously and loads
of functionality built in but we did
break out in the initial release
of you know for the physics project we
broke out certain things like you know
um causal and variant q or branch pairs
or whatever
um as
also as separate functions
yeah
right so it makes sense to do that here
as well
if there are obviously important
functions which are totally obscure to
have as properties
right and i agree that the things like
this i mean retractions is a plausible
even this left inverses thing is sort of
a plausible because it is returning a
function it's a plausible thing to have
as a property
but again i think we just don't know
what um i mean i'm not even sure that
breaking out causal variant q and branch
pairs was necessarily a good idea
because they're not that there are other
things which i might have actually
preferred to break out in the end like
things to do with branchial graphs and
so on might have been better to sort of
factor out i think i think the fact that
we factored those out i don't consider
to be a particularly
uh you know necessary thing
so i think they were fine they would
have been fine just left as properties
um
okay so a similar thing is you know for
these for these very general
constructions like equalizer limit etc
which are so you know as we've
established these are really like
category schemas
does it make sense therefore to have you
know for instance for abstract limits to
have an operator form where you get the
category schema and then you apply it to
a particular category
um which is kind of the design i was
thinking about for actually
instantiating these universal properties
well i don't understand how you get an
accent schema i mean maybe sorry a
category schema
you've that thing there is just an
abstract category isn't it
no no this is the point right so um
again let's let's go back to a really
simple example let's take say um no i
got the point that it's not i'm just
asking structurally in the system what
is that what is the head of that object
it's abstract product it it is its own
thing
which is a schema you'll see
um and so
why don't you just feed it as a sub
value when if you feed it a category as
a sub value why doesn't that instantiate
it
well it probably should but i mean
okay sorry
dumb question what exactly do you mean
by sub value i mean you just say
abstract product
you know of blah blah blah and then of
something else well no that's exactly
what i mean by by operator form right
yeah
you would take this you would say blah
of cat
exactly concrete category oh yes that's
what i'm saying
that seems like a very sensible way to
do it okay i i agree i just wants to get
that sound right even though it is a
little bit of a of a sort of illusion
because you could also put in there a
property
and as a string but a property as a
string is definitely not a category with
head you know abstract category right i
agree i agree
um
yeah no okay you combine abstract
product and these other constructions
and just use abstract limit
is there something by having the simpler
cases
separate
well okay again this is kind of um
this question here right like
so
i i'm still not entirely decided as to
whether it makes sense to have things
like equalizers coequalizers products
copyrights pullbacks push outs as
separate functions or just have them all
be part of these mega limits and
co-limit functions they're basically
restrictions on what
the
like index categories you're using are
right exactly and they come with special
naming you know default naming
conventions and stuff
um but apart from that they the only the
only reason i thought it made sense to
have them be separate was because they
are all of them are very common
categorical constructions so i feel like
yeah but maybe there could be like the
one function with convenience syntax for
all of them
right i i
again like category operation and then
it's what the operation is for example
although that's i think a little bit of
a wimp out
so like for a product your index set is
a finite
uh category
right
that doesn't seem completely crazy to do
that although
i mean one might then ask why isn't it
just category limit etc
it depends on how many there are
if you tell me that there are like five
maybe they should be separate functions
if you tell me there are 25 then there
really shouldn't and and also if there
are ones that are really obscure
i think it's better to have a string
thing because more like entities then
right i mean so the ones that are
currently implemented as separate
functions are the really common ones
right
or or do you do you really want
different representations of the
different kinds of cones
and you could pass those in
[Music]
that would also be a uh yeah quite a
nice way of specifying it
um also that would probably be nicer
than string arguments
because it's essentially the same
operation like you're saying but you're
giving different input
which thing what are you suggesting
like
so products and equalizers these are
limits for different kinds of cones so
suggesting maybe we could have
certifications of the cones
that's more complicated than i mean it's
more i don't know the category theory to
be able to
validate that
i mean
okay i'd like to also comment let's see
go back to your list of of issues i mean
i think this generated variables
generated names thing does need another
look
um because i think that's otherwise
going to
uh
i mean okay and this one okay this was
in the original version of the the
agenda but now i so i'm i'm currently in
the process of rewriting how natural
transformations and indeed functors work
this i think i've now solved most of
these problems um this was kind of a
question
uh so anyway so very soon natural
transformations will be back working
again so you can have
transformations between functors and you
can reason about you know natural
isomorphisms and things like that what
is it what is a natural transformation a
natural transformation is a structure
preserving map between functions
so if you if you have functions f and g
between categories c and d then you can
define a that you can define natural
transformations between f and g
okay general knowledge question what's
the relationship of you know
mappings between functors mappings from
natural transformations natural
transformations what's the relationship
between that and higher category theory
uh okay so in
right so you can define something called
a functor category where every uh where
every object is a functor and every
morphism is a
is a natural transformation
and in the context of functor categories
then this process of building up you
know successively higher order natural
transformations corresponds to uh higher
morphisms in strict higher categories
um so that whether it's like strict
higher categories you mean in
well strict
like as in not weak higher categories
how does that i don't even know what
that means what is weak height what does
weak versus strict mean
well okay so you know you know what a
higher category is
i think so
[Music]
like this
uh and then because these two morphisms
are between the same objects i can
define a two morphism between f1 and f2
and i ca and but i also have say g1
uh so and you also know that there are
like two different notions of
composition that exist between the the
higher between the two morphisms so
you could have horizontal composition
where you can say now uh if if alpha
goes from f1 to f2 and beta goes from g1
to g2 then because the codomain of f1
and f2 and the domain of g1 g2 match i
can compose alpha and beta horizontally
to obtain
you know beta horizontal compose alpha
and i can also have vertical composition
where i have something like this
so f2 f1 from
so f1 f2 f3 all map from x to x to y so
i can i can compose f1 f2
with alpha and f2 f3 with beta and now i
can i can vertically compose beta and
alpha and beta to obtain a morphism uh
two morphism directly from f1 to f3
right okay
so uh so i have so the um so both and
both um
for a strict two category both the
horizontal and vertical composition
operations have to satisfy the axioms of
a category they themselves have to have
to satisfy associativity and
or at least have to satisfy
associativity
um
if you have a weak two category then
they only have to be associative up to
natural isomorphism
um and so it's a much weakened so so
most of the time strict two categories
are a bit too strict for most of the the
constructions that you would care about
and what you actually want to do a deal
with um is deal with week two categories
and then this extends when you do this
inductive construction so you have go to
three categories where you have three
notions of you have you know horizontal
composition vertical composition and
some other direction of composition in
some third direction you know in some
third dimension
uh there you know all three of them
would have to satisfy associate all
three notions of composition of three
morphisms would have to satisfy
associativity either strictly or up to
natural isomorphism
so
uh
anyway
that's
i think i need to absorb that more
more carefully um all right
go ahead
on to another question which is like you
know do there are lots of possible
extension you know
i'm trying basically to get as much of
the the core functionality
implemented and well designed but once
all this is done there's no reason in
principle why we couldn't support you
know
strict two categories
um you know three categories and so on
and you know higher groupoids higher
compensative diagrams those kinds of
things um
is there an argument for doing that
well i would say that things that
eventually sort of connect to the
physics project and so on i'm highly
interested in seeing done
i mean i think that look i think there
are two points one is how does this
connect to other parts of the system
and two is how does it connect to the
things that we're understanding the
physics project and so on
those seem to be the two obvious
directions for you know i mean and i
think in terms of how it connects to the
rest of the system i suspect that the
instancing of categories with specific
f's and g's and so on and you know
specific objects in fs and gs and so on
like for example ian maybe you can say
something about how our symbolic work on
topological spaces and so on relates to
all of this
could we plug that into this
um
yeah so if if find equational proof for
or
or you know if we had some kind of
prover that could handle set theory
then maybe what we did with topology
theorems could be like a test suite
like see if the prover can prove these
things
but i mean in terms of the entities that
we've got could we
you know these categories these are
abstract categories here as you've said
but
we could imagine concrete things where
this is a category of i don't know
groups and we're we're dealing with
actual
things with particular groups and
mappings
in that light like you could say the
topology entity store is basically just
um
a bunch of theorems and definitions in
the category of sets
okay but can we feed that into this
category theory framework and have it
conclude useful things
in other words could we could we
concretify these categories in terms of
actual you know sets and i mean you know
groups and commutative groups and and
you know group what about the category
of vector spaces for which we have the
morphisms which are the linear operators
our matrices and we can check whether
they are left invertible right
invertible things like
that right
like the way we would state that a
function is continuous in the in the
entity stores was just saying like f is
an element of
the the hom set for
the
category top
okay you just don't know what what was
that symbolically we just have a named
category called
top
and then you say things are are either
objects or morphisms in it
but so the question would be in linear
algebra for example is category theory a
useful way to organize certain facts
about linear algebra
well this is the point that i already
raised in relation to the quantum
framework right so there you have
exactly a concrete category equipped you
know it's a category equipped with a
functor to fd hill
um the category of finite dimensional
herbic spaces and then
you've got you know then you're in the
domain of doing categorical quantum
mechanics
um
and then you know in the same way if you
have a way of representing symmetric
monolith categories and string diagrams
in those
of those symmetric monolith categories
then if you have an abstract category
with a
with a faithful functor to vect the
category of vector spaces then you can
do diagrammatic linear algebra
which is its own
thing
and that's tensor diagrams that right
uh right right so so um tensor networks
are a special case of monoidal string
diagrams for vector
okay
i mean that's something that we've been
independently interested in with respect
to sort of our generalization of array
operations
does anybody here know about that we've
had that in a um
um
we were talking about that i mean
threaded is our first adventure in that
in terms of that kind of thing but there
is a belief that there's more that we
can do
in terms of generally jose do you know
about that
there's some and we're talking about
tensor diagrams as a way to generalize
what we're thinking about with arrays
or am i confused here
i don't know of a connection with
category theory this is this is very
abstract for the sort of thing i i
usually do with
fair enough
um
okay we should probably wrap up here i
see some comments on our live stream
from
rbs asking why are we using that circle
dot for composition yeah we discussed
that earlier in this in the stream
um that we don't really want to use that
we want to use something simpler we
would like to use the pure function
composition thing but that will evaluate
and we got some problems with that and
it's kind of a symbolic version of that
that we formal version of that that we
need
um
it's a question which i don't understand
from
universe can groupoids be nested i don't
know even what that question entirely
means
is there an obvious answer to that
question jonathan
um
i'm not sure i understand either
okay all right fine
but um
with any categories you can glue these
things together right you could
um
and so you you could in effect you can
in effect do the analog of recursion
on categories if that's what's being
asked
but
well i i guess this category schemas i
do wonder to what extent they can be
thought of as categories with blanks
that are i mean to what extent are they
like lambdas of categories and to what
extent are they like categories with
blanks and so
on well in effect i think they're
exactly like categories with blank
in
a sense like something like this n is
just sort of anything that matches if we
imagine having a pattern object
this is just that's just that pattern
right
um
yeah which which suggests that maybe we
should treat these
category schemas as things with pattern
objects in them instead of literal
objects for
uh objects little literal objects as
objects pattern objects as
this sort of schema objects
right right which is again implicitly
what we would be doing if we included
four alls and we did a theorem version
of this
yeah except that the relationship
changed for all and patent variables a
little bit obscure
well not not for the untyped blender
calculus of the theorem proverb they're
they are the same
right i understand
um current from obvious about smart
graph theory yes in the earlier part of
the stream jonathan showed that this
thing can eat all this category theory
stuff can eat
you know graphs
and you can apply graph operations to
these categories in fact i bet if you
say simple graph what would happen if
you did that to that one there
uh
and in general if you take a ca i mean
that that thing there was not a category
it was a category schema but in general
if you take a category
uh
like
i don't know this
um
category three and you say rather than
reduced label graph you say simple
labeled graph it will strip out all the
multi edges and the um sorry category
iii it will strip out all the multi
edges and all the self loops and just
return the simple graph
right it is very nice that these tagged
edges work so smoothly with this
i mean that you can then just do pure
graph operations on these things
you you can can't you i mean they are
there if you look at what that thing is
it is just a graph of tagged edges is
that true
um and as as we discussed earlier and as
um roger kind of brought up earlier uh
essentially all of this kind of fancy
universal algebraic stuff that we're
doing most of it just internally is done
with with um with graph operations
um
like which
actual algorithmic lifting is
just arthuritic
which means that we can scale up to
industrial size category finite
categories
which is nice i mean where is where are
those used giant other than the physics
project where we have like mega sized
categories
um where else do people use industrial
styles categories
i don't i mean
like i say in most actual category
theorists will be dealing with non-small
categories um
yeah
you mean something different by i mean i
mean people who use category theory as
an organization scheme i mean like the
people who are doing sort of chemistry
related category theory
like that um the kappa people and so on
what do they do they they have finite
categories don't they
uh yeah right or at least so what okay
generally in those kinds of so with
things like cat lab and and kappa and
all you know other things that do that
use category theory as the underlying
formalism for some larger computational
framework most of the time what they do
is they have a formal semantics that
involves
you know
non-small categories and then but then
they claim that at any point in time
you're only ever reasoning about a about
a finite subcategory of it
i see
i mean and then there are these things
to do with data validation and so on
that use category theory although i
wasn't it seemed like not totally
convincing and really using some kind of
type theory instead
is that true or is that um
right although i mean a lot of the time
the the theorem provers that that are
used for kind of verification of typed
um functional languages very often they
are category theoretic in nature
um
like what
well i know
like a bunch of the type um
a bunch of the type checking in ghc for
instance in the glasgow haskell compiler
is you know effectively uses
compositional theorem improving
techniques
what is composition author improving
well i mean they're improving that uses
sort of the framework of category theory
and of the theorem provers
which ones do that i mean there are ones
that are
what you say go ahead well because of
you know because of curry howard lambert
any theorem that uses um you know that
uses at least to simply
use at least simple typing uh
will be well everything in that theorem
proverb will be interconvertible with
something to do with categories
yes
okay but i'm still not be nice to know
what is the is there like an obvious
killer theorem which needs typed lambda
calculus to prove it
since you said ordinary induction can be
done a different way
uh yeah although i mean this is
this is far from efficient
i mean just as yeah it's
i mean that darren poover whoops that's
their improvement the one that um
the boya moa theorem prover thing wasn't
that an early what's that which is now
called enqueue
nqthm i think
okay
but i mean that that that theorem was
specialized in induction kinds of things
if i remember correctly right yeah i
think that's i think that's right
but
and um
okay well this looks quite lovely i mean
really really looks great i think again
just as a practical matter let's get
some meeting to just look at the graphic
design of this um and let's uh i mean it
looks to me like if you have a
comparatively modest number of functions
what what is going to happen
implementation is this going to be a
packet that exposes itself through the
function repository or what
i think that makes sense for the moment
so so right now we have on the
the framework it all told has on the
order of about 20 functions i may be
able to simplify some of that
um
and so it seems like the the best thing
to do is yeah as you say have it be a
packet repository thing with exposed
things with exposed stubs in the
function repository
sounds sensible to me anybody else with
any other comments on this
just would have been really helpful when
uh studying these things in grad school
it looks good it makes it i think it
will be helpful for a lot of people to
understand it now we have to
make this framework and then we can make
a little course around it so people more
people can actually understand this
stuff including people like me
um
anyway okay
good
um all right thanks very much and um
thanks driver